the new Twitter files releases out the
coup de gras as Elon Musk calls it Matt
tahibi reporting that the FBI was
directing Twitter to take down accounts
he called it Twitter FBI subsidiary when
you look at these emails it's even more
clear that Twitter was basically just
working at the behest of the FBI
whatever the FBI said the funny thing is
they even wanted to ban the FBI did
Billy Baldwin okay I know he's not the
favorite Baldwin brother but come on you
know Banning the guy apparently over
satirical posts and we can see in this
the actual emails where they're going
after people who are posting jokes and
that's what Twitter was okay with they
were okay with doing this there's some
really great uh comments and memes about
this the FBI claiming that they're
fighting election interference created a
unit to Target Twitter Facebook Etc and
to interfere in elections we got a bunch
of other news too the one that really
riled me up today is the uh Revelation I
shouldn't even call it that most people
should have known this but journalists
didn't do their jobs I was late to the
party for sure it's that the guy who was
posting Elon musk's uh Elon Musk Elon
musk's jet was actually cracking a
private number called the Pia to reveal
private information on Elon Musk that is
Elon Musk took great measures to conceal
his own his privacy of his jet this guy
used a bunch of different data sources
and Bots to track down and
algorithmically figure out which plane
was his and then go guys I found him
okay that's not public information the
media's been lying about it so it's
basically just a whole bunch of Twitter
news this Twitter employee who is spying
for Saudi Arabia has been sentenced to
42 months we got Ben Collins of NBC has
reportedly been suspended over his
disparaging comments about Elon Musk
they said it was not editorially
appropriate so so uh once again Elon
Musk is the main character in all of
existence and we're going to talk about
what's going on with uh censorship free
speech and all of that before we get
started my friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from
BioTrust BioTrust aqueous multi collagen
it's unflavored it's awesome you need it
for your joint Hair Skin and Nails you
know for me I I was skating today I've
been skating quite a bit actually
skateboarding today and as well as
rollerblading and as an aging man I got
to make sure that I'm getting my my
collagen and so that's what we have here
if you head over to strongerbones in
life.com you'll get a 60-day money-back
guarantee you will get five key types of
collagen you need from four different
sources essential to optimally support
an array of full body benefits for every
order today BioTrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids police out BioTrust hit
their goal of six million meals this
year it is non-GMO and free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners nearly no odor or taste
unlike bone broth and other collagen
supplements there's no clumping unlike
other collagen supplements you'll get
free shipping with every order free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again that
is stronger bones in life.com thank you
BioTrust for sponsoring the show and
don't forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member if you would like to see
our massive library of uncensored shows
Monday through Thursday at 11 PM we put
up a show it's about a half an hour to
45 minutes typically and we have a whole
bunch of conversations and a wide range
of issues you can go through that whole
Library plus you'll be able to see cast
Castle Vlog tells me inverted world and
we have other updates your membership is
also supporting a whole bunch of other
strange and crazy Endeavors like we're
open opening a chain of coffee shops so
that we can have a physical presence in
various areas and have a bigger impact
culturally there's a lot of work we got
to do so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all of these
issues and more is Sarah Gonzalez hi
thanks for having me I promise not to
wear a mask covering my face and walk
out 20 minutes that's all we ask 27
minutes sorry 27 27. I mean I might do
it at minute 28 but okay that's fine
just you know you got to be you got to
be yay who are you what do you do uh I
am with Blaze TV I uh I host a show
called the news and why it matters and
uh over on Blaze TV I encourage everyone
to watch it I also uh God you asked me
this I have several things that I do I
own a a makeup brand American Beauty by
Sarah uh yeah I just said screw Sephora
and Ulta I want to empower women to be
real women and you know be proud of that
and I also run an initiative called
defend our kids Texas where we are
trying to prevent the sexualization of
children in the state of Texas not
Nationwide yet only because it's we just
got to tackle our state first but we
intend to take it nationwide right on
well thanks for hanging out we also got
Luke hey guys my name is Luke radowski
here of we are change.org I am your
humble t-shirt Defender and and today
I'm wearing a t-shirt that says all my
favorite YouTube channels have been
demonetized or deleted probably by the
FBI and if you like the shirt and you
like thought-provoking YouTube channels
that the FBI doesn't you could get the
shirt and help spread this important
message on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
guys do that's why I'm here thank you so
much for having us Hannah hi I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for Tim
called you Hannah
yeah my mom's ghost is gonna come in
home okay
mother named me but I guess you can be
just what is it what is your name Hannah
Hannah okay see I got it I got it Hannah
you said it I said it you said it I said
it it's okay Leroy doesn't have to
listen to me he he wants to I said your
name
cease to Mom that's an interesting
I don't know it's not like I don't know
why I'm gonna say your last name that's
not my last name you don't no one asked
you to
oh it's okay we also have Kellen what's
up everybody's on business yeah just uh
I love the debate between Leroy and
Hazel so it's always a good episode I'm
pushing buttons let's get this started
all right let's talk about this big news
man The Daily Mail reports FBI deep
State team of 80 people regularly handed
Twitter lists of people to ban including
actor Billy Baldwin and satire accounts
new Trove of musk's Twitter files reveal
Matt Tybee posted a new Trove of Twitter
documents on Friday they show emails
from FBI officials requesting bans on
Twitter users how dare they go after
Billy Baldwin that's the most shocking
thing of all so here's here's one of the
emails it's uh from what from fbi.gov
Twitter folks please see below list of
Twitter accounts which we believe are
violating your terms of service by
disseminating false information about
the time place or manner of the upcoming
election let us know if you decide to
take any action against these accounts
based on your your uh our Tipper to you
also let us know if we need to issue you
a preservation letter as we intend to
serve legal process for these accounts
thanks for your consideration there's
something that I found really
interesting in this latest release and
it was that
Matt taibi goes on to say he he had an
FBI agent reach out to him who told him
that most companies deal with stuff like
this with the FBI but they're
adversarial he said T-Mobile is
absolutely adversarial the FBI agent
said that when they send a request to
T-Mobile and get it wrong T-Mobile
employs a leak the communications
causing problems for the FBI that's the
way to do it I like me these T-Mobile
people and there you go push back on
this stuff but look at what we got here
I mean this is this is amazing some of
these emails are just straight up like
thank you for your patience as our team
assessed the I'm sorry that's from
Twitter some of these emails like one of
them was just like please see these
accounts that need to be removed and
then it's like okay then they come back
and they're basically like yep we did
what you asked thanks uh thanks boss
that's uh this is the current state of
our elections I suppose the scary thing
with all of this is that
80 FBI agents
shutting down jokes satire and what they
deem to be misinformation
it's wild
at the same time that how many other
things were they missing because they
had this many FBI agents looking at
jokes and satire on Twitter all of the
child trafficking right exactly
we've got a crisis happening at the
border and they weren't missing that
they chose not to do anything about it
they prioritized the satire over content
that was dangerous to Children Well they
did a little bit more than that let's be
honest here with the activities of the
FBI for 30 years when victims were
coming to them they're just you know
ignoring it but there was 13 year old
children coming to Twitter being like
hey there's an adult video of me here on
this platform please remove it Twitter
said no that video got 160 000 views 2
000 retweets and Twitter after they
verified the identification they're like
yeah we're not just going to do anything
about it as they were in constant
contact with the FBI I mean are you are
you kidding me and and the FBI
micromanaging our political discourse is
not a surprise here they're doing this
not just with Twitter they're probably
doing this with YouTube they're probably
doing this with Facebook book A lot of
these coordinated attacks especially
when it came to censorships were with a
lot of platforms acting together in
unison many instances and for years I've
been screaming these are not private
platforms there was always a debate a
couple years ago saying they could do
what they want they they they're a
private organization this is what
capitalism is all about and I was
screaming off the top of my head no this
is not capitalism this is the government
essentially uh creating a KGB like
political Purge on the line destroying
political speech here orchestrated by
top levels of people within the
government this has nothing to do with
private entities this is your tax
dollars being used to censor your speech
your humor your comedy and who would
have thought the FBI doesn't have a
sense of humor huh yeah and I think you
know um uh you said it and I think it's
it's so true people so often say um well
I mean we already knew that this was
going on so what's the big deal and but
there is it takes a certain level of
sheer arrogance to say we're going to
accuse the other side of doing all of
these things we're going to accuse them
of Russian collusion we're going to
spend two years and millions of taxpayer
dollars to look into this you know
totally bogus thing meanwhile we know
that this is what we're actually doing
we just don't think that they're ever
going to find out because we control
everything yep
so while for the longest time child
abuse videos are on Twitter you've got
an FBI agent sitting there in his van
you know eating a bag of Cheetos and
he's like scrolling through Twitter
looking at all the exploitation videos
like and then he sees a guy whose name
is ultramaga wangamaga hat saying don't
forget to vote trumpet
she texts Twitter immediately like get
it off get it off I mean I'd like to
believe that's an exaggeration but I'm
it probably actually what happened yeah
I mean what else what else do you think
happened here they they were giving out
almost daily reports of individuals that
they wanted censored by by them because
of Comedy because of humor because of
satire I mean how more egregious do you
have to get I mean this is I mean making
people laugh is not a threat against
National Security unless you're the FBI
and you see that as a threat questioning
of course mainly Authority uh so I mean
I think we're only just scratching the
surface here with these Twitter files
there's a lot more coming I think
there's a bigger FBI involvement here I
think there's definitely a lot more back
Channels with what we have seen
throughout the last few years and I
think it's not just the FBI I think
there's also other branches of the
government participating in these kind
of larger political KGB purges uh
including of course Dr fauci's team
which Elon Musk actually teased was
going to be released soon as well so I'm
very lucky I'm very much looking forward
to that myself I don't know about you
guys do you remember when they just
dropped what was at the first or second
Twitter uh file dump and Elon himself
said that this was a violation of the
First Amendment and people kept you know
calling back to him like that's not true
because it's just the Biden campaign
they weren't in office yet you can't
prove that and you know it was painfully
obvious to all of us who have been
paying attention that first of all when
you have a a campaign an incoming
campaign obviously they don't like lose
touch with these same Twitter contacts
that they had but you know secondly Elon
has seen behind the curtain right like
he's seen it all so of course he's going
to know more than what they've dumped
you had to expect that he was going to
come forward with confirmation of active
government you know collusion I mean
didn't Katie Hobbs wasn't their email
from the cases
can you take this down well yes but
their argument was well that doesn't
count because it was just a campaign
they weren't actually part of the
government yet well what is the argument
now because that seems like oh I know
and now all of a sudden they're silent
yeah it doesn't make any sense I find
myself thinking like what recourse do
any of these people have though like are
we expecting that one day we'll get an
email from Elon Musk saying by the way
here's the evidence that you need to try
and you know if you are in a sympathetic
District get a ruling from a judge to
get some kind of compensation from
Twitter like what are the consequences
that anyone involved this will really
face realistically I think it's good
that it's coming out but I would like to
see more and I don't know how that's
pursued that's a great question to ask
but it's also important to add a
different layer to it because what
effects did this censorship have I think
we need to ask ourselves this what was
the what was the result of them
censoring political thought and
expression who was more in favor who won
who benefited off of these censorship
actions uh that's a question that I
think is pretty clear and obvious but
what extent was it done I think there
needs to be more investigations more
studies and very surprisingly Matt Gates
came out and said that there's a lot of
questions that he has for the FBI that
him and his colleagues are going to be
asking very soon in Congressional
hearings but this is just the beginning
I think we need we need a whole church
commission style hearing we need a whole
uh way just to have total transparency
of exactly what's going on here because
we still are only seeing a small portion
of it and I bet you it gets more rotten
more nasty and more seedy than we could
even imagine it and right now yeah I
agree uh especially with the
Congressional hearings because I mean if
his history has proven anything what we
heard fauci we know he committed perjury
we heard uh Jack Dorsey it seems like he
committed perjury we've got a long list
of people who seemingly commit perjury
in front of Congress and nothing really
happens to them so what are the
ramifications you go up there you lie
you go home everyone knows you're lying
and nothing happens yeah law enforcement
Society it's all it's all broken yep I
mean you look at almost every
circumstance of Street violence from the
far left unaccountable unaccount like
there's no accountability none so why
would if conservatives don't respond in
any meaningful way
why would any cop stick his neck out why
would any member of Congress actually go
after this why would any law enforcement
agent uh agency actually go after this
there is no upside it's that simple you
go to any member of Congress Republican
or Democrat I shouldn't say any but most
of the Republicans you go to any law
enforcement agency and say here is
someone advocating for violence doing
something awful or committing violence
and they'll say well you know if we
arrest them antifa will show up and
firebomb the precinct if we don't we
don't got to worry about it and
conservatives don't do anything anyway
so no upside right no reason to do it
but you got it back to Blue you know
well if you don't back the blue you know
these things
listen here your little commies here
someone made a very interesting comment
uh in the chat room right now he says uh
you know you should look at Rules for
Radicals because one of the tactics
there is to ridicule uh your opponents
as being one of the most effective ways
to kind of use humor against your
enemies so I think this is one reason
why the FBI was going after humor and
comedy so much because they know how
effective it is because when we look at
our modern political landscape politics
is everywhere A lot of people are sick
of politics but if you could crack a
joke if you could make people laugh you
can make them think and I think this is
why we have seen the weaponization of
the Jon Stewart show we saw how popular
it was and we saw similar kind of forms
of entertainment being formed by that
probably with uh State uh you know State
Park participation and I I think this is
something that we shouldn't uh you know
because some people are going to say oh
it's just comedians don't worry about it
no this had a big effect I think on our
society more than we could expect
especially with the chilling effect
stopping other comedians from saying
that spicy joke or making that spicy
comment that stopped the discourse from
progressing in our society one of the
revelations we got here we got a tweet
here from Matt taibi an internal email
from November 5th 2022 the FBI's
national election command post which
compiles and sends on complaints sent
the SF field office a long list of
accounts that may warrant additional
action and what what I find truly
shocking here is at RSB Network right
side broadcasting network this is the
FBI reaching out to Twitter saying
scan through a news organization's feed
to see if they broke the rules now I
understand that we're in a new era and
it's hard to separate an individual
account from like a news media account
but so long as these journalists want to
play the game I will come out and say it
right away the FBI
telling Twitter to take down an
individual wrong
the FBI telling Twitter to take down a
news organization now that's where it
gets real creepy they say
this is the email asacc Chan the
national election command post anycp is
requesting assistance from SF regarding
coordination with Twitter specifically
any CP has been made aware of tweets by
certain accounts that may warrant
additional action due to the accounts
being utilized to spread misinformation
about the upcoming election specifically
NS necp is requesting the following one
coordination between SF and Twitter to
determine whether the accounts
identified Below have violated Twitter
terms of service and may be subject
any actions deemed appropriate by
Twitter
two the issuance of preservation letters
regarding this account identified below
in order to preserve subscriber
information and content information
pending the issuance of legal process
and three any location information
associated with the accounts that
Twitter will voluntarily provide to Aid
the FBI in assigning any follow-up
deemed necessary to the appropriate FBI
field office now there's a lot of names
in here you got Billy Baldwin of course
down at the bottom but RSB Network that
one uh that one stood out to me they're
directly the FBI was directly trying to
shut them down what do they do they live
stream Donald Trump speeches for
instance things like that what date is
that I can't see
this is November 6 2022 right before
this midterm didn't Elon Musk already
buy the platform at this point
I think he I thought it was like end of
October yeah he did
so Elon he was still going through
everything you know at that point and
there's uh some leftists who are
roasting him saying how many FBI agents
still work at Twitter and it's kind of
like you know that's not an own right
that he doesn't know that that the FBI
infiltrated this company the the
estimates uh that people are sharing
around and talking about is that there's
about 15 uh individuals connected
previously to intelligence agencies uh
to organizations like the CIA and FBI
that have been working at Twitter at the
time that uh Twitter was acquired by
Elon Musk so uh why does uh online
social media company need spies to work
for them I don't know but that's a
question that I think a lot of people
should be asking themselves since
um again 15 people from the intelligence
State going from working as the CIA to
Twitter why I see I would ask like
what's the reciprocity right like if
you're an intelligence agency and you're
going to let someone go right you're not
going to offer them a new contract they
have security clearance to go work for
Twitter like what is Twitter getting
from you I don't think this is a one-way
Street it's not the FBI only getting
stuff from Twitter what protection does
the does Twitter get from all of the
agencies that it recruits from I mean I
I also I would love to know that as well
I also would just say I feel like
Twitter bred a culture that they
probably would have just welcomed it
without any any repayment right without
any reciprocity because whatever they
can do to get the narrative that they
want to get and you know they've got the
FBI giving them cover almost right
because they're like well the FBI is
telling us to do it so we got to do it
darn you know I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if they just did it just
because they're like oh gotta do it oh
will it will it influence elections ah
gosh darn it or or they had dirt on some
of the high-level Twitter employees like
yoel yeah they might have caught with
some precarious uh you know material
understand the computer and then the FBI
is like hey we got you on this uh you're
pretty much our uh female dog now we're
gonna do what we want with you
um so the time to ban all the satire
people now family is a friendly way of
saying it yeah that's yeah a very family
friendly show here very professional uh
here all the time non-stop all right now
to get not family friendly Matt Tybee
tweeted instead of chasing Predators or
terrorists the FBI has agents lots of
them analyzing and mass flagging social
media posts not as part of any criminal
investigation but as a permanent and in
itself surveillance operation people
should not be okay with this yet for
some reason all of these woke
journalists are really really mad that
Elon exposed this they're doing things
like mocking it as nothing or just
saying there's no news here they're
downplaying it to the best of their
abilities now that's strange why why
would anyone do that why would so
so-called you know Anarchist socialist
revolutionary types sorry sorry look
they do call themselves anarchists so
they're not they're Communists they're
commies why would they not what
shouldn't they be excited the FBI is
being exposed for these illicit
undertakings
not when they've been working with them
and benefiting them for so so many years
now and essentially putting their
putting their opponents in prison right
on the surface level of course we could
go back to you know the Occupy Wall
Street days it was a totally different
political landscape that landscape has
changed and a lot of people are becoming
bigger and bigger statists depending on
the government depending on them to
carry out their own kind of will onto
others and uh it's sickening I I it's
it's it sucks when I don't care what
party does it but when you start to
imprison people for their political
beliefs when you start to impose your
personal beliefs onto others uh I
believe that is uh you know a recipe for
a disaster I don't think America's built
for this particular way and it's showing
us how biased everything is how unfair
everything is and how only it's going to
be more unfair from here oh well I mean
what you're saying too is that these
people don't have true morals or
convictions that they live by they just
as Luke pointed out they just want to
impose their will on everyone else so
when it's convenient they'll love things
like freedom of speech and freedom of
the press and when Donald Trump threw
out one CNN journalist from the White
House Press briefing room but left
another CNN journalist from the White
House Press briefing room you know the
first amendment was under assault and
you know he was such a threat to
journalism now all of a sudden you're
seeing this and crickets because they
don't actually have those convictions
they have none they just pretend they do
when it suits them I think the only
thing they actually have is they're a
raucous mob and they just want to see
more mob violence there's no end goal I
I view it like a chaotic destructive
force it is a fire it is destroying it
is spreading and we need to put that
fire up that's it because you look at a
lot of the positions they take they
don't make sense like according to the
woke left Luke is a person of color I'm
not kidding wait recognize yeah because
because Luke is Slavic he is not white
despite the fact he is a white blonde
hair blue-eyed man that's why my voice
is most important here but he's not the
right kind of blonde-haired blue-eyed
person right no you're or white despite
you know you guys having similar hair
and eyes but Luke's not yeah yeah
stay in your place and that's and that's
I've always been fine with it it's okay
it's because
quest for political dominance they are
using sophistry and any ridiculous
argument possible
that's it yeah I mean you can't you
can't make sense of the you know the the
illogical I mean they do it all the time
with all of the uh the drag queen stuff
that I'm exposing right they're like
well but yeah no it's we it's it's
family friendly there's they're just
dancing with the just the cleavage and
but then you know they talk about
Hooters and all these other things and
you're like wait it but can we all can
we just agree can we can we have a moral
can we have a value and can we agree
that if it's wrong it's wrong and then
let's just live by that no because no
one can't do anything to be gray area
because then you can they can move you
more and more away from what you believe
is wrong right if it's the great if it's
great it's negotiable uh I find myself
thinking when we read this tweet about
all the True Crime fans that are out
there right now who are big on like
researching old cases and stuff and it's
like if you ever get to a case where
there were the FBI were like we don't
have the resources we don't have the
time to help you like remember this is
what the FBI has been doing you know
like any time there's a crime where you
actually need the FBI's assistance and
resources and access to whatever
technology like they're busy on Twitter
yeah but dude I mean Mean Tweets that's
true I forgot my feelings they might
hurt someone's feelings I was talking
about look the the kids they've already
been exploited someone's feelings could
be hurt and they could stop those
feelings from being hurt
there you go I was logic I was talking
to um Brian on the way here and we were
talking about uh you know I think Ted
Cruz was asked recently when all of this
I think it was after the FBI raided
Mar-A-Lago and Ted Cruz was asked about
it and he made the comment I think we
should defund the FBI
and they took it and they tried to act
as if he had said something so crazy
conspiratorial controversial they're
like Ted Cruz said we should defund the
FBI and I'm like yeah
and
I'm sorry is that explosive yes we
should I think it's funny that there was
a period 2020 they're like deep on the
police and the rights like now now come
on here you're going a little far with
it and now the rights very much like
well you know I don't know about
completely but um there's certainly a
lot of law enforcement problems
especially at the federal level yeah now
the conversation but what I loved is
that when the when the Right started
embracing abolishing the ATF the IRS the
DEA and the FBI and the CIA the left
started mocking them I'm like whoa whoa
guys guys if you want those things too
you've clapped for them but a lot of
these people on the left don't actually
want these things well they want it on
the federal level they don't want you to
have a state police force but they do
want you to have Central authoritarian
control well they're they're it's it's
the Democratic it's the Multicultural
democracy versus the constitutional
republic the Constitutional
republicanists or constitutional
republicanism wants there to be
decentralized to a certain degree with
you know various jurisdictions and the
left is the multiculture Multicultural
democracy that wants no no jurisdictions
but the federal government top down
tells you what to do the Mob Rules
there's also a lot of conservatives
calling for that too A lot of them who
wear CIA pins a lot of them who call for
more Federal governments and more
Federal interventions and more Foreign
Wars so there's also a neocon aspect to
this that I think does get addressed
that has been kind of unfolding within
this kind of right-wing party which is
uh very interesting to see because it's
kind of counterintuitive to itself when
you see that do you see do you find that
it's mostly like older establishment
type people who have been in politics
for a very long time well like Sean
Hannity I think Sean Hannity is a
perfect example of the Old Guard who
wants government loves government loves
the intelligence agencies loves back the
blue and the police uh and is it isn't
open to criticism of his own party of
their failures so I think those
individuals are very different than
individuals like Tucker Carlson who are
able to criticize individuals like
Donald Trump who are able to question
the Deep State what Tucker Carlson said
last night about the CIA and the JFK
files was extremely eye-opening and very
brave of him to do that so I think when
we have individuals like that there's a
big difference within this kind of
right-wing party that I think is not uh
coalesced together I wanna I wanna jump
to the story because uh my friends Elon
Musk is in desperate need for of our
help of our help because the media is
lying about him and I'm only half
kidding actually I tweeted Jack Sweeney
was not posting public information Jack
Sweeney was posting the private
information of Elon Musk and he knew
Sweeney is the guy who ran the Elon jet
account Elon Musk suspended him and all
the journalists who linked to his
private data Elon had what's called a
Pia it's a privacy icao address that is
his aircraft address was private and
rotated every month I want to show you
this archives I linked The Source Jack
Sweeney January 26 2022 he said Elon got
Pia but I've already identified it
confirmed on paa but I'm all good here
still he even said that Pia does make it
harder but he can write code to figure
it out this is not publicly available
information this was a guy who used code
and Bots to algorithmically crack the
identity of elon's plane so that he
could publish that information and Elon
made one mistake he tolerated it he was
because he wanted to be a free speech
guy he says I'm diving I'm not even
going to ban that that account
well he should have instantly so some
people are saying well Elon got rid of
his PA recently and I'm like look
if Elon was spending money for a private
rotating address to avoid being doxed
and it wasn't working he was still
getting doxed I'm not surprised that he
would eventually say what's the point of
paying for this or doing it but this is
what the journalists are lying about The
Intercept issued a statement saying our
journalist was late was was suspended
for for sharing public information but
it's not public information
so the funny thing is I can Google
anyone's address I'll find it I'll find
your name phone number address in 10
seconds it's public information you
still can't share it on Twitter all of a
sudden they're defending this and
they're lying about it here's the crazy
thing back in January one person
responded is there a way to take his
concerns about his own safety seriously
but still do this it's really cool to
have this but I don't know it just feels
odd you're a heck of a coder too
one person said please stop already
unfollowed other people cheered him on
some said why are you doing this but the
fact that you had people responding to
him being like yo this is dangerous
and he didn't care
yo this this is what evil looks like
someone who knows what he's doing is
wrong cracking someone's privacy address
and then when he was when this was
addressed because Elon so I tweeted
about this actually Elon responded to my
tweet just saying correct I don't know
if we have it right here he said correct
Jack Sweeney responded by saying Elon is
trying to say what I'm posting isn't
public information adsb and a cars are
all over public frequency and are
acquired by organizations blah blah blah
blah blah it's like saying am and FM
signals aren't public you see how he
avoided addressing the fact that he by
he cracked the Pia number yeah he's he's
because he knows what he did was wrong
in fact Elon even insinuated that what
he did was illegal that by compiling
public data to expose the Privacy
address of elon's plane and then sharing
it publicly that he actually was
committing some kind of crime I don't
know if that's the case but here's what
he wrote he said yeah so the Pia icao
can be changed monthly if chosen to do
so but even then it's relatively easy to
identify I'm confident I can write
software to identify it actually that
was in February and Elon tolerated it
and be because he did as soon as he
realized just how dangerous it was and
finally said enough they tried calling
him out oh but you said before you
wouldn't do it well my attitude is that
was Elon being nice yeah now he's nuking
you yeah I mean it's it's really
infuriating
um to to hear you talk about this
because I hadn't you know I was
traveling today so I hadn't heard this
the rest of the story because just on my
show we were talking about this and we
made a comment that it was odd that he
mentioned when he first announced that
Elon jet was banned he mentioned that he
had some legal you know he's like I'm
already pursuing legal ramifications and
I thought to myself well hold on what
does he have he must know something else
because how how does he think he has a
case if this guy wasn't doing something
illegal if it's publicly available
information you have no case right so
but it's infuriating because I love you
know I'm looking at all of these places
who are supposed to be journalists
trying to find out more information no
I'm finding out from from alternative
media right that's where you find find
it out you don't find it out from any
mainstream media Source Elon Musk also
responded to Ariana Jacob who tweeted
I'm not famous and I wasn't a public
figure either when Taylor Lorenz asked
for my address said it wasn't for
publication and then proceeded to dox me
in the New York Times with the address
she had assured me wasn't going to be
published the article was shared many
times on Twitter and this is uh Elon
responding saying such shameful Behavior
will not be tolerated going forward
last night there was a a big space that
Elon went into a Twitter space these
chat rooms right had like a hundred
thousand or some ridiculous amount of
people and it was a bunch of woke
journalists and left-wing activists and
Elon came in and said journalists you're
not special if you docs you'll be banned
thank you goodbye and then the crazy
thing about it was that several
suspended accounts were able to actually
be in the space it was fascinating to
listen to these people who knew nothing
about what they were talking about they
were saying things like tracking planes
is publicly available information
incorrect they said you know if you're
on a plane anyone can post the tail
number or whatever it's like yeah but if
you're flying commercial no one knows
who's on the plane elon's plane as
elon's plan it's him or his family
so they didn't they didn't quite
understand understand this and the most
important element for people to
understand private airport terminals
typically have no security you can
literally just jump a four foot fence
and be on the tarmac at one of these
airports these are small Regional
airports often sometimes they're on the
back of a major airport and they'll have
some like maybe an eight-foot fence but
that's it it's a chain link fence you
you in in uh let me let me teeterboro
teeterboro is is the New York area
airport where most people try to fly
into because JFK and LaGuardia if you do
want to fly into their private
tournaments it's very very complicated
so it's much I don't even know if they
have them but it's easier to fly into
New Jersey
the road is about 25 feet from the
tarmac that means if somebody is
tracking elon's jet in real time they
can pull up their car knowing he's about
to land and they can be ready for
something truly awful and they can be in
the building there's no security perhaps
a problem
but when they're publishing the private
information of Elon Musk and then lying
about it there is a very serious
security threat the last thing I want to
mention on this
listening to this Twitter space you know
Brian stelter comes in and congratulates
them on the scoop it's just deplorable
Behavior but the one thing I wanted to
say but there's no point in going in
these room and saying it so I joined a
different room with Nuance bro and a few
other people and I just wanted to point
out a couple weeks ago or about a week
and a half ago
a couple men broke into my house smashed
the window climbed in fortunately I was
not there because we go to Great Lengths
to keep our security uh you know to
maintain security and so for whatever
reason these guys thought I was there we
believe it was targeted so uh uh shots
were fired at them they then fled
if somebody was tracking my real-time
location like on a jet or a car
I could be dead
not just me many other people and so
Elon gets to experience with his family
the other thing I hear is the left now
saying Elon didn't file a police report
on the guy jumping on his car
and it's like their their view of law
enforcement comes from movies there's
two things to say to that first why
would law enforcement help anybody right
now especially someone like Elon who's
associated with the far right or
whatever but more importantly hey shout
out to Luke for you know the back to
Blue sarcasm why would in law
enforcement without doing anything the
other issue that people don't realize is
that the amount of time and energy that
is required to deal with these things in
the legal system it's months it's tens
of thousands of dollars or more and it
pulls you away from your job and there's
nothing you can do about it and the
state could even get involved and
victimize you the victim already so if
someone breaks into your car and attacks
you and you decide to call the police
the police can then say you've got to
give us your records you've got to give
us your phone you've got to give us
these things you have to appear in court
on these dates and you can't say no so a
lot of people who know this and are well
off are probably like we are better off
not filing a report on this one
wasn't there video of the the guy
climbing onto the hood I don't know
about climbing on the hood but there's
video of the guy they said did it
wearing like what looked like black okay
so so they're saying that the video that
that he made up well there has to be
videos because uh I I bet Elon and his
family don't drive anything else but
Tesla's so Teslas usually have cameras
everywhere filming everything yeah uh so
I there has to be some video of it but
you know a cop a lot of the times the
cops show up they're like what do you
want we all want to report like okay guy
jumped on your hood I didn't want to get
hurt no okay have a good night that's
that's essentially how a lot of cops act
like okay can we can we generate some
revenue for the state here can we give
someone a ticket no yeah okay I I'm busy
kid that's that's just you know now
would Elon Musk be treated differently I
don't know maybe but uh in many of my
personal instances the cops weren't
helpful at all and many times they just
don't give a damn they just don't care
so I don't know if they would be
actively doing something against someone
jumping on a hood especially when it
comes to stalkers there's a lot of
people that get victimized by stalkers
and there's very little that you could
actually do about it yeah stocking's
really difficult to have evidence for I
mean a lot of times it's like you said
someone was here when they weren't
supposed to be and now they're gone so
what should we do about that like if
they come back let us know oh this guy's
standing on public property he's not
doing anything right or it's like if he
comes back that would be the worst thing
right so I'll let you know after he's
already killed me thanks right you don't
you know what I want to do I'm gonna I'm
gonna dig a moat around our next
headquarters no I'm not a dropper you
personally that was the idea that's what
I said from the beginning
we gotta have a big moat and we gotta
have two communities one's a centralized
government one one's an anarchist one
we're gonna see which one thrives but we
gotta have a moat the centralized one
will Thrive but it will be less
comfortable all right uh we'll see let's
let's play out this experiment I think
it would be interesting I think the
centralized side will be very very fast
it's able to turn on a dime but people
will be more they're more likely to be
unhappy I think in the anarchist side
people would be chilling but it will it
will grow not as quickly this is what
your memberships are funding yes I think
it's worth it yeah
doesn't want to see them it was also
interesting to see Barry White Barry
Weiss criticize musk for Banning these
journalists and he kind of responded
what would you would have done if
someone was live doxing your kids it's
an interesting question because again
there's also a lot of possibilities for
these new rules to be interpreted in
many different ways that could actually
stifle journalism let's not say that
there's not a slippery slope here
because there is I think that still
should be addressed in some kind of way
but again a lot of this is personal a
lot of this emotion is emotional rather
than actually being based on any kind of
logic or principles let's talk about
this we have the story from timcast.com
Barry Weiss criticizes musk for
suspending those reporting on private
jet story pundits respond Elon Musk
himself responded to her as Luke just
mentioned saying what would you do what
is your solution to real-time doxing the
issue I take with this as we get into
the story is journalists think they're
above the rules they think well someone
already published the private
information therefore it's okay for me
to do it now I was talking talking to a
prominent leftist and they were actually
saying these reporters were just
reporting they shouldn't have been
banned and I said but it's private
information not public information this
person responded and said it's already
in the public I said okay so if one of
your enemies one of your detractors post
your address you don't mind if we'd on
our show will just hold up your address
because it's already public information
right of course not of course they don't
want that it's sophistry they're coming
up with excuses so here's what happens
Barry White says the old regime at
Twitter governed by its own whims and
biases and it sure looks like the new
regime has the same problem I suppose uh
I said I oppose it in both cases and I
think those journalists who are
reporting on this uh reporting on a
story of public importance should be
reinstated
a lot of people criticize Barry Weiss
for this Elon Musk came out with a
legitimate question for her what is your
solution he then said it's not
rhetorical legit a bunch of leftists and
started mocking him saying he's His Own
Worst Enemy I actually think this shows
integrity the fact that Elon was willing
to give information to a journalist
who's not completely on both of them
shows he's going to be getting some you
know blowback from this because it's a
he's he's doing the right thing by
giving out the information but I don't
think Barry Weiss is completely wrong I
will say I think it's it was probably a
bit
um fast to give a seven day suspension
instantly without warning what should
have happened is he probably should have
deleted the tweets automatically and
then issued a warning where they lock
your account saying you cannot link to
this you have been warned we have
deleted the Tweet there definitely needs
to be some kind of procedure there
definitely needs to be some some strict
rules that people will understand and
follow and know if they break or don't
break but before the show began I posted
an image of a famous character
celebrating and being happy with the
caption journalists when people get
their account suspended and then that
same person being miserable and very
angry when journalists when other
journalists get their account suspended
so there's a lot of hypocrisy especially
when it comes to the corporate media
because essentially they didn't care
they didn't give a damn they celebrated
and cheered on the censorship of
everyone else but now that they deal
with it now all of all suddenly they
start to care about this issue here so
maybe some people are saying that this
could be 4D chess of Elon Musk trying to
get the corporate media to care about
censorship because they do now as of
course it's important to note here ABC
NBC CBS News all ignored the Twitter
files the Twitter files that expose the
government working with big Tech
censoring political speech that's one of
the biggest stories of our decade that
deserves a lot more coverage CNN only
covered it once so now
they kind of have to cover it and they
kind of do care about the censorship
finally I've heard a lot of people
saying like oh look at this Barry Weiss
is turning on Elon or whatever and I'm
like no I I actually agree with Barry to
a certain degree
that we are still I got a phone call
from a journalist they asked me they're
asking me about how Elon he responds to
certain accounts and this journalist is
like it's a journalist I know and
actually trust by the way I don't trust
a lot but someone who works for the post
and they were just like you know Elon
responds to people like Ian miles Chong
and you and I was like whoa me I was
like no you're mistaken like I think
he's tweeted at me like two or three
times in you know for forever okay one
of them was about being Iron Man like
not a lot not a legitimate thing these
other people he tweets it all the time
like he follows them really really
closely he's not following me and they
were like oh and I was like yeah uh I
actually think it's a problem that's
what I told him that we are once again
just living under the whims of a
billionaire that being said elon's done
a whole lot of really really good things
so if we've gone from corrupt crooked
billionaires and millionaires working
with the FBI too
an emotional billionaire Who's acting on
his whims but outing and exposing
government corruption I will take it and
showing the hypocrisy of the corporate
media Keith olberman who was banned is
literally using his dog's account right
now in order to ban evade and he's
tweeting videos of him you might have
heard I got banned so he's so addicted
to the platform he he just can't get off
of it sorry I cut you up no no you're
fine I just was gonna say
um you know I find it uh fascinating
that no actually no lost it
Keith olberman's dogs here's here's the
here's the post he look Elon if you want
to rule with an iron fist there's one
thing you can do
people like this
just ban them just Ben Collins just ban
them okay Keith olberman band Griffin
band Kathy Griffin the reason is these
people are hyper emotional extremists
who post insane inflamed rhetoric
Ben Shapiro partisan conservative rather
tempered I think he put out a thread
where he was like I don't think these
journalists should have been banned
despite the fact that I don't like them
rupar is a bad journalist but if they're
reporting like he's got his opinions
he's got strong opinions but he's not
going on Twitter and screaming at the
top of his lungs and shaking his face
like Keith olberman does Oliver men
calls for like military rendition of
people it's just psychotic rhetoric but
it works you know who I'm I'm starting
there's a follow
I recommend and you two guys the
krasenstein brothers
do you guys remember the Crescent scenes
are they wait are they back they're
better they're back oh and they're great
and they're great so uh I actually had
that I'm blocked and muted they come
back and I unblock and unmute them
because I guess they reach out to
someone and said hey Tim's got his block
and blocked him and they posted some
funny jokes
they're actually having sane rational
conversations about what's going on they
they
um I think Brian posted something about
you know if the reporters are publishing
public information it shouldn't be you
know banned I responded with it wasn't
public it was private and Aaron rupar
one of the journals who got banned
admitted to linking to it and the
response was interesting points can you
provide more information and evidence I
sent it to him and he says very
interesting I still think there should
be a procedure for this that people
understand I said you are correct wow
that's fantastic that is a guy who hates
Donald Trump who has called him out and
annoyed a lot of people but actually
having a real conversation and saying
okay disagree with you on that one but
that that is correct I I gotta agree and
I'm like that's the kind of rhetoric you
want Keith olberman is the opposite he
ban evades he's got he look look he's
unkempt he's he he's ranting I mean let
me play some of this for you for not
doing something he claimed he would
never Donnie O'Sullivan Ryan Mack it's
the baptism scene from The Godfather
movie and we all got whacked by Don Elon
musklione for a moment last night I
thought you know he did this just so
we'd all forget about Donald Trump's
stupid baseball cards from yesterday let
me talk about that too plus thurber's
the cat bird seed this guy desperately
needs to be Cut Off from Twitter I'm
sorry he's just like reading off this
terrible stand-up routine that he's been
rehearsing he's reading tweets on paper
he's got other people's but dude you
need to go touch grass every time I
watch one of his videos I think to
myself doesn't anyone in his life love
him enough to get him the help that he
needs apparently not he must just be
that kind of a person I can't help but
bringing Donald Trump into these
everything every this is an Elon Musk
story exclusively oh but let me talk
about Trump and his nfts like hey I'm
not a fan of the nfts but come on man I
love people will tweet at me like touch
grass Tim and it's like dude I go
skating almost every day I ride I've got
an electric motorbike that I ride around
I'm in big fields and there are trees
and there are deer there's too many deer
guys like no isn't
a year ago there was like three now
there's like 15 on my lawn every night
I'm getting worried but I'm I'm out here
you know getting away from the city
I'm on Twitter
posting jokes and ish posts and nonsense
because I I just think it's all silly
these people live on Twitter and are
frantic and ranting and calling for I
think it was Oberman who called for a
military rendition of Donald Trump and
it's like dude
like Elon he said some time away from
Twitter would do him good
yes okay just i p ban him and just give
him a week a week for him to go outside
and just stare at a rock or a tree and
then come down talk to your neighbors
man yeah I mean I'm pretty sure he lives
in New York City and I'm pretty sure he
might be like
um like what's his name Howard Stern and
uh kind of afraid of
the flu going around I want to go back
to it came back to me the point that you
were making about Elon um and it's like
okay we're making a little bit of
progress right baby steps but I also
think it is important and I'm sure you
guys have talked about this but I think
it's very important for people to
remember because there are a lot of
people on the right who they're like the
the nerdy kid at the dance they're like
oh my God someone finally likes us
please yes invite me to the dance and
it's like he's not I would not say he's
with you on all things we'll take the
win when we can get it right but like
he's a transhumanist he's a big you know
uh climate change guy like let's
progress is progress let's take baby
steps we'll take the wins where we can
but like don't get too trusting in just
this one guy like he's going to be your
savior I think Elon will ultimately
strip Twitter to its Bare Bones and a
lot of the things that are being talked
about with rev share and stuff probably
won't happen very very loose prediction
right here I don't I don't know if it's
likely or not I'm just saying here's
what I see we got a report that he's
seeking new investment
for for Twitter so he they just opened
up at a at a 44 billion evaluation
offering for investors to come in
because he wants to offload that debt he
has that debt is going to bring I think
a billion dollars per year in interest
he's got to get that down Elon even
tweeted don't hold debt in a you know
environment like this then he sold more
Tesla shares I think he sold was like
three billion or three point something
billion clearly he's trying to get that
debt down but Twitter probably is not as
expensive as people think it is to
operate it is a very rudimentary service
when you think about it it's hosting
text granted videos and photos if you go
back to the early days of Twitter when
you wanted to post a photo or video you
had to use a separate third-party
service this is like 10 years ago and so
if you went on Twitter and posted an
image it would then go to a different
company that would automatically post it
was like you you'd approve an app or
something like that but Twitter was just
text they they expanded they added all
these features it became very expensive
what I think is going to happen is
elon's got a secure investment and paid
on the is debt he will probably be able
to be able to pay down the debt but then
he's got to get costs way down they're
not getting enough Twitter blue users so
what I think will ultimately happen it
will probably just maybe from where we
are right now there's a million and one
variables standing before us I think
Twitter could eventually become a
decentralized fetiverse Style app which
will just be a massive Community he sold
uh 3.6 billion dollars worth of a Tesla
stock just recently and uh it's going to
be interesting because I don't see him
kind of doing that I see them I see him
kind of moving forward with the X app
the app of everything the WeChat of
China here in the United States uh but
he it's important to know here he fired
what was it nearly half of it hey staff
eighty percent eighty percent of the
staff at Twitter and the app's working
better than ever I know like Twitter's
amazing right now everyone wants to be
on the app including Keith olberman
who's on his dogs
including Kathy Griffin that's on her
Dead Mother's account this is the place
to be where you have the conversations
of of literally yay saying Shalom so so
when you have such craziness unfolding
on this app there's a lot of High Hopes
I think he has a lot of high hopes to
make it the app of everything the next
WeChat I think that's that's pretty
clear but it's the debt financing that
has me thinking it may turn into
something a bit different maybe it does
become the X app but it won't be this
hyper-centralized monolith it'll be some
kind of decentralized app that has these
these plugins in it for doing certain
things like Payment Processing but the
the debt's massive and the fact that you
know he said what in April he's not
going to sell anymore or something like
that then he sold 3.6 billion
yeah you know he's he's got to find the
cash he's got to get rid of that 13
billion dollars in debt apparently some
big investors are interested and I do
hope they get involved but the media
attack is Relentless all of the
reporting is like why would anyone
invest in a company that's burning
advertisers and bleeding money and it's
just like it's it's mostly not true but
they're trying to destroy Twitter
it's funny as soon as they lost control
they tried setting fire to it yeah ain't
that the truth yeah if they can't have
the narrative nobody can so in the end
if Elon can't pull it off
decentralized Federated social media app
and I think that may be better
you know I think back to web 1.0 and it
was so much better back then but it was
probably better because the only people
who used it were
I don't know how you describe it driven
individuals individuals in the know when
the internet was dominated only by those
who sought out to use the internet and
not by people who had to use the
internet it was wild it was free it was
fun there were weird websites there were
gifs of Macho Man you know dancing and
there was crazy music and then once the
internet became a utility for the
average person everything homogenized
and solidified into basic programs you
got your news you got your your game app
you've got your banking app and
everything is apps everything's placed
into a little box no more Wild West no
more fun a lot of people have talked
about how can we get back to those days
well Elon Musk has has lit that fire a
little bit bringing back free speech to
a certain degree and then you know
kicking out the narrative but uh I don't
know if we'll get back to that point
potentially through you know Federated
networks and things like that as an
aside too I guess we move on apparently
I don't know if this is true look if you
heard this that Twitter's banned linking
to passed it on directly now
um I'm not I can't clarify that I I
haven't seen that myself personally I
don't believe them yeah like these live
tests are like you can't even link to
Mastodon now I'm like yeah you're lying
about something I do you guys ever get
depressed thinking about the fact that
you know Elon has made some changes to
Twitter and that's great but
imagine what's lurking over at Facebook
and YouTube and you know all these other
places where are we ever gonna get to
the bottom of that no
I always think about what did they do
like the people that were running
Twitter before weren't dumb they left a
bunch of evidence but I'm sure they
scrambled to delete a lot yeah this is
just what we found this is only what we
found so I can only imagine what yeah it
had a year to do it yeah that would that
that sucks and this could be why these
latest documents are coming from uh you
know things that happened under Elon
right yeah because all the other stuff
could be still kept uh hidden in secret
so uh I mean if Elon said this was the
coup de gras
I mean you know seeing the FBI make
direct requests for takedowns is huge
but is that it come on yeah I don't have
a lot of Hope in Congress but there are
going to be some hearings from this
there should be huge National Senate and
Correctional hearings into all of this
and we should get everything that's
happening behind the scenes uh there
there should be a total disclosure
because if the same FBI agents are going
to Twitter they're probably also going
to YouTube they're probably also going
to Facebook so if they are subpoenaed if
the files aren't destroyed or deleted or
covered up which they probably are
there's going to be links to other
channels there's going to be a bigger
kind of onion unraveling here so
um
yes it is it is it is this is what we
know this is what's on Twitter side
imagine what's on the government side
It's gotta get really depressed that's
really dark for me to think about like
God this is disgusting and this is just
scratching the surface wait until you
find out about the island that they go
to yeah
unless you make it all public all of the
accounts are what was the term de
amplify side have no way of knowing that
they were targeted and without that
evidence you know not that I think
they'd get a fair day in court but they
are completely reliant on big Tech and
Congress working it out they have no
chance to advocate for themselves they
need to be able to say hey look here's
the communication here's the list that
Twitter and the FBI put me on saying
that my content should be limited I mean
if we don't make this public to the
people who were affected themselves
we're just stuck in the same Wormhole
right we're dependent on bigger
representation to take care of these
things which it's it's almost impossible
to ask them for especially if you're
thinking about seeking monetary damages
or anything else right yeah and I know
that Elon said that he was going to have
some sort of a way for people to find
out if they were being suppressed
somehow but I don't think that he
clarified whether he meant whether they
were suppressed currently like in that
moment or go back in history and look to
see if they had been suppressed at any
moment in time right I would love to for
him to clarify on that I mean I know
he's got a lot of stuff going on but I I
think this is something that should be
given priority I mean I appreciate that
this is something you know that he wants
to roll out systematically and there's a
timeline he wants to establish but I bet
there are a lot of people who if given
access to a database of this information
know they could find themselves on one
of these lists and who would be willing
or have the support to do something
about it yeah
we'll kiss that uh Government funding
for SpaceX goodbye I mean with all the
people he's upsetting oh yeah you know
can we can we give a shout out to uh
Mike Lindell who's back on Twitter to
Jim Hof the Gateway pundit who's back on
Twitter and of course James O'Keefe who
is back on Twitter uh you know him
you'll love him I'm glad to see that uh
Elon Musk is Banning the fake news and
restoring the real news and Robert
Malone and Peter McCullough that's right
so back on the platform I um today it's
not good days I think that it's you know
you're talking about banning people for
satire and comedy and stuff and how that
was wrong and I don't disagree with you
but I do think it's important to take a
step back and say like well it's not
just that right like people still should
be allowed to post something that's just
completely inaccurate as well it doesn't
have to be that it's satire or comedy or
anything else
um but uh yeah it's it's nice to see
especially James O'Keefe man he's been
doing such great work yeah lately
absolutely I am going to uh I'm gonna
pull up a story real quick while you
guys it's gonna say that Keith Oberman
uh reminds me you know how like they say
the people who are addicted to the
social media are like teens like
especially teen girls and you take their
phone away and they freak out like I
feel like that's actually Keith like
he's more important
right he's so addicted to the likes and
reactions on Twitter that he is like
going on to his dog's account he can't
be away from him I actually like not
really know that much about him before
this and it's such a weird impression so
uh I wanna I wanna I wanna pull up this
story because this is a juicy one it's a
little off subject but I saw someone
super chatted it and I want to get it up
just the news says Arizona judge
approves Kerry Lake's request to examine
ballots the inspection is slated to
begin at 8 A.M next Tuesday this really
surprised me it really surprised me
judge Peter Thompson on Thursday issued
the ruling which allows the inspection
of random ballots in the in the county
ahead of the trial date the Republican
had previously filed a request to do so
and Arizona law provides for a candidate
challenging election results to demand
ballot inspections to pair so Thompson
granted three of Lake's four demands
allowing the inspection of 50 random
ballot on demand printed ballots 50
random early ballots and 50 random bod
ballots marked spoiled the judge denied
her bid to inspect 50 50 random early
ballot envelopes which is weird but
either way this is huge this is Carrie
Lake's election contest moving forward
to an evidentiary point now there is in
the ruling that if the if if the case is
dismissed then this is vacated basically
but uh with Trump in 2020 all almost all
of the court cases that they had were
dismissed on standing you can't do that
here Arizona law prescribes for this
kind of action so I don't know exactly
what they're going to find but there's
already witness testimony coming out you
know uh as as evidence and with Carrie
Lake being granted the ability to
inspect these random balls what she
wants to do is 50 bouts from each
different place so this may actually be
50 random 50 uh 50 random Battle On
Demand 50 random bod 50 early and it
could be at like every different place
in Maricopa County so I guess my my
question is I wonder what ultimately
will come from this and I don't really
know what else to say from it I'll say
about it other than I think this is this
is massive still could potentially
result in nothing if carry like is wrong
about everything but what do you think
happens just hypothetically they've
already certified Katie Hobbs has
certified her own election for in favor
of herself for winning
but what happens then to to YouTube's
rules what happens to Twitter's
misinformation rules if next week on the
20th they do the random inspection and
find like a 17
inaccuracy or something some people have
already pointed out there was one post
that a three percent margin of error is
greater than the margin of victory that
means if they do these random samplings
and find a very small sample of of bad
counts
something then what happens
I mean I don't know where to go with
this one I'm just like it's big I mean
it depends on like Arizona's law right
if it's big enough well it depends on
the judge really right and if it's a
random sampling like if if enough of
them are messed up at some point like we
need to study a bigger slash maybe all
of them I mean this is something that
could take a really long time to get
clarification on at a certain point like
I hope that Carrie like has enough
backers willing to you know donate to
her legal fund because this is going to
be an ongoing fight for a long time
imagine
the 21st comes around they have the
trial because that was the trial date
this is 20 and 21st I think the 21st the
20th and 21st what happens if a ju if
the judge issues a stay on Katie Hobbs
becoming Governor just like the
political ramifications or whatever that
means would be crazy that's why yes so
then who's Governor right Ducey
says yeah he just stays in office the
thing is they get done I've got a
normalcy bias I cannot imagine that
happening because it would be so
shocking to all of us but if it does
oh man but I don't think Carol Lake's
gonna give up I think she will push it
until the end and so like it is going to
be on Hobbes and I guess the election
officials in Arizona to either be like
no we have enough evidence to prove
you've been a loss or they're gonna have
to acquiesce that there was something
wrong but what I kind of you know here's
where I'm at right now with this
there's a lot of people who are
screaming fraud and all that stuff and
I'm like I don't know about that but I
am willing to bet that with universal
mail-in voting and the way they handle
this they're not doing signature
verification as rigorously as they used
to which means I would not be surprised
if Kerry Lake can actually find a
percentage high enough through the
random sampling to at least throw
everything into question which could
result in what a stay of you know her
being inaugurated whatever the word is
or or or or then what a new election how
would they deal with this I mean this is
crazy I also would really like to know
the judge's reasoning behind not
allowing the early the envelopes yeah I
know that's kind of weird it is weird
just be like sure look at the envelope
whatever right I don't know unless they
don't maintain the envelopes like
there's if all the counties don't have a
consistent policy in which is the
envelopes like maybe you can't get 50
random samplings this is just
speculation on my end also this makes me
want everyone to read their State's laws
regarding elections like if there's a
close election in your state what does
your state allow you to do because like
without this law it'd be really easy to
just deny care like her day in court
here's here's here's something I think
people should consider too I don't know
what's going to happen in this it's in
court we'll see but you have to imagine
with everything that happened in 2020
and the accusations about Arizona that
carry like behind the scenes was was was
placing those chess pieces in the right
order you can't be someone who believes
Trump was right about 2020 and not
cross your t's dot your eyes and do
everything possible to make sure that
when this happens
surprise surprise Carrie lake is now in
The Fray challenging it she tried she
tried suing Earl way before the election
saying the machines need you know need
need to work and they said no standing
because the election didn't happen then
we had the tabulation error and she sued
saying I told you so it's like the fact
the court system operates that way is
broken as it is yeah but I I'm willing
to bet that Carrie like Trump's allies
probably put a bunch of money into into
planning for a legal maneuver after the
election because they expected something
like this yeah it's also frustrating
though to watch her being painted as
this crazy conspiracy theorist you know
because of her history of questioning
previous things uh that's all I'll say
on that but
um it's frustrating because it just
feels like such gaslighting that they're
like oh look here She is again
questioning another election she's crazy
she's never going to you know abide by
democracy whatever they want to call it
and so I think like it's just
frustrating to watch her being gaslit
because here you see she has Merit when
she came out and she gave that big long
uh I think it was her last video that
she did where she detailed what all is
involved in the lawsuit I mean if she
can back that up if what she had if what
she's saying she actually has that's
huge yeah I mean she's saying they just
randomly came up with all of these
thousands of votes out of nowhere you
know they found them and something is
wrong or whatever right I don't know
though they're like there there's some
claim that a witness said they saw about
from a dead person I don't know about
all that that's what the court is for
but if that turned out to be true that
this is why I say normalcy by it's like
ah come on like if that actually was
exposed in court and they like couldn't
deny it it would the whole country would
erupt it would be the craziest thing
ever I but I gotta be honest
we're getting close to 2028 you know
fourth turning and all that you got the
antifa guys in in Georgia who are uh
that store with the antifa guys they
were setting homes on houses on fire
they they uh a guy was in his truck and
they started bashing it he jumped out
they flipped it and set it on fire so
like you know when you hear stories
about antifa doing that kind of stuff
and that's now antifa has an autonomous
Zone in Georgia right now and it's just
not being reported on probably because
people are just like oh yeah it's normal
now it is normal to hear stories of
antifa setting up autonomous zones I
literally I literally had no idea that
that was happening yep in Georgia like
today right yeah five of them got
charged with terrorism which just okay
like the other day they just and so that
autonomous Zone's been there and we
don't even know about it because it's
just no journalist cares nobody's
nobody's tracking it nobody's reporting
on it they can't really You Know cover
it because you know they get beat up if
they do sure sure also they're
anti-fascists so they're the good guys
right right I don't think you understand
yeah no but my point is it's become
normal yeah come on if you went back
even four years and said that far left
extremists would be C amazing parts of
their cities and creating up creating
autonomous jurisdictions people would
laugh at you and call you nuts and now
it's it's it's happening you know I
don't want to say it happening all the
time but it happened again and we had no
idea they were doing it well there I
mean they're normalizing degeneracy just
all across the board though it's not
just with antifa it's with you know I go
back to the sexualization of children
and things like that they you show them
something that's sexually explicit and
they're like yeah what's the problem
it's just completely normal to them
they're they're they're they're gutting
the culture of America
they did gut it and as I was saying
earlier I think the main issue is that
for any Corporation for any law
enforcement there is no upside to
standing up for America and independents
and conservatives
yeah they're not going to do anything if
you defy the left they will attack you
they will try to kill you they will burn
down your store if you defy the right
conservatives Grumble on Twitter not
only that like if they go after the far
right everyone cheers if they go to
conservatives conservatives back off and
complain if they go after the left and
liberals antifa shows up with crowbars
baseball bats and mount off cocktails
and it's frustrating too because being
in you know uh the kind of the activism
Community I'm constantly like guys we
are in the spot in society where we are
because everyone sat at home and didn't
do anything right you kept your families
you minded your own business you said ah
Live and Let Live I'm just gonna mind my
own business and meanwhile the left took
culture and we see how much they eroded
it so now when I go to them and I say
are you ready do you want it do you want
to get active they're like well no
because now this is the culture and I
might get fired right I can't
participate because if my boss finds out
that I'm a conservative they might can
me and then and I have to feed my family
so what's the answer but it's only
because conservatives don't stand up
that exists I know that's what I'm
saying right so you're stuck in this
cycle of like well he's gonna do it
right that's what I'm saying
I'm saying all the
stop it we are here because you guys
said I'm going to sit around and mind my
own business and let the left do
whatever they want these Libertarians I
tell you okay
you want to start this again let's go
let's go right now did you see what Dave
Smith tweeted uh uh he said Tim pool
Michael null Tim cast Michael Knowles
and Luke aren't allowed to talk about
libertarian Community without me or
Michael Mouse present it was it was it
was three on one uh and uh I I thought a
lot about the stuff that we we talked
about I thought I could do a lot better
but specifically when it comes to what
you were just mentioning there should
also be a lot of blame on the Bush
Administration I think the Bush
Administration pushed a lot more people
to the left and I think they were like
hey we can't have these crazy people
starting we're stealing all the money
giving all the money to Halliburton
screwing over the soldiers and screwing
over the American people spending more
money than they ever had I think the
Bush Administration truly wasn't
listening to Libertarians wasn't
influenced by Libertarians was uh an
Administration that truly put us on this
path that we are right now setting up a
deep State setting up a war on Terror
that now is being turned around against
Republicans and conservatives so uh you
know to make to the point to to
Michael's points even last night he
specifically said oh it's Libertarians
that created a situation where
conservatives are this bad no it was it
was Republicans and conservatives that
screwed themselves and created this
situation that there was a bigger
pushback against uh he also mentioned
specifically Vietnam if you look at uh
and uh the cultural revolution in the
60s what spurred that on Vietnam the
assassination of JFK which the
government by the way the CIA is still
keeping thousands of documents secret as
of today not finding out exactly what
happened there and it was also the CIA
that was also dosing people with acid
pushing a cultural revolution so there's
a lot of different things to kind of
examine here and take a step back when
it comes to blaming everything on
Libertarians I'm I'm triggered so I'm
gonna read this chat comment uh I'm not
necessarily triggered but uh Stone says
Mr millionaire Tim Poole you have you
have to risk it all and um the way
interpret that is like I'm doing really
really well and there's little risk so
there's an old story about the sort of
Damocles I'm sure y'all have heard it
right
the dude goes to the king and says oh
how glorious it would be to be king and
he says how about I let you sit in the
throne for one day and be king he says
oh joy would be me and then when he goes
and sits in the throne he looks up and
there's a sword hanging from a single
horse's a horse's hair right above his
head and he goes I don't want to sit
here anymore and he was like you think
that sitting in the throne is real great
Until you realize everyone's trying to
kill you so um what does it mean to risk
it all it's a good question we certainly
are comfortable because of the success
of the show and I really do appreciate
everybody who's made that possible but
uh there's also a bullet hole in my
kitchen because two men targeting us
smashed through the window and climbed
in and that was actually not even the
first incident I can't talk about the
other ones there's also some other
things I can't talk about that happen
today because if I went and told you
about every single time someone
committed a very serious crime against
us then that's probably all we would
ever talk about so risking it all I mean
this is the way I kind of see it which
is frustrating I understand for the for
the average person it's very difficult
to to step into The Fray to say to their
company no I get it you know I don't
have a family that's that's one rest guy
don't have and you do
and you're willing to bow to the corrupt
and the evil if it means shielding your
children for the time being but the end
result I suppose is just going to be
your kids living under the same boot
for me man and I mean honestly for for
everybody who's here and works here when
someone shows up and and breaks in or
sends us death threats or we get you
know my family gets threatening phone
calls I kind of feel like we are taking
big risks doing all this when we could
probably just make like a gaming channel
and you know walk away from everything
so I've talked about it before where it
would be so much easier just to quit
retire
take whatever I've got and just go live
in the mountains and say I am done the
risk isn't worth it but I can't do that
the risk is what comes like the risk is
what we accept in order to fight the
fight in order to challenge this and
that means that uh I have to obfuscate
my location it means that there's
probably gonna be more people who try
and break into my house and who do break
into my house and there's going to be
more gunshots and eventually there will
be critical injury from it and things
will get crazy
I can walk away from all that I guess if
I didn't want to risk it so I kind of
Envy the people who are sitting you know
at their house you know they're playing
video games with their kids thinking I'm
not going to say anything and I get what
they're saying but far be it for me to
be the person take the risk I'm jealous
of that you know I'd probably just
prefer to go to the skate park every day
and then just you know I could have
taken the money I got from Disney when I
worked for him and never had to work and
just lived in a van and said screw you
guys you're on your own so I don't know
man
I think that like to a certain extent
you are open it's easy for people to
criticize you that you don't take enough
risk they don't really see all the risks
that you do that you take and it's a
trickle-down effect everyone at our
company takes but I would go one step
further and say you have to think of
that Ronald Reagan quote all great
change in America starts at the dinner
table like you are in a position to take
greater risk because you have you know a
bigger public platform you might have
more resources but like if people are
not at home with their children
discussing like openly what their values
are and what values they want their
children to carry into the future it
doesn't matter how many risks every
public figure takes right like if we
don't live our principles day by day you
could take as many risks and put
yourself in danger all the time but
ultimately the influence is limited like
people have the ability to take risks
themselves even if it's not standing up
to their boss but to be open with their
children I can't tell you how many
people I know don't discuss what
American culture is with their families
they say well we we don't want to talk
politics with our children we don't want
to talk about our history like there are
risks that and opportunities for people
every day you don't have to have a ton
of money or a huge following on the
internet to do this like you have to
live your values and I think that's why
I don't know it's it's a it's hard
because you do take a lot of risk but
also like you do it because you believe
in what you're doing people can take
these risks in their personal lives be
more open with their friends about what
they believe or what they won't tolerate
they just choose not to because it's
uncomfortable I also yeah you know I I
dealt with a lot of crazy you know
security things throughout my career too
also you know physically involved in a
lot of crazy stuff a lot of the stuff I
don't talk about I know Tim you don't
talk about the stuff that you deal with
as well but you know you just got to
take it one step at a time yeah you got
to be smart you got to make sure you're
not going to be a victim uh I started
you know learning self-defense in many
different ways and instances and that
also helps gives you gives you peace of
mind here but it's crazy out there and a
lot of the times people don't understand
like the crazy-ish that we had to go
through that I had to go through through
like from Chicago with the police
officers from you know interrogations
from getting jumped and attacked from
the the things that are happening at the
home here this is just like the
beginning of of a lot of others very
serious things to come so personal
defense is more important than ever I
also think just go kind of going back to
what his comment really was I took from
that you need to be the guy because we
just need figureheads saying these
things we don't need to be doing them
meanwhile contrast that with the left
who has infiltrated the medical
community they've infiltrated Taco Bell
they've infiltrated the education I'm
not kidding Starbucks they've edu
they've they've infiltrated all of these
different places right their boots on
the ground they're going in and they are
getting it done and and then this
Viewpoint is just like well you just
need to be our guy and so be it you're
the rich guy you need to put yourself
out there and do it and it's like do you
do you guys not see that this is why
we're losing because they're over there
are doing the work that needs to be done
infiltrating in the community to change
the culture and we're just over here
like well you need to do it all for us
the story about Taco Bell was a guy
wearing a mask that said black lives
matter and his manager said you can't
wear a political mask at work and he
says I will not take this off and they
said then leave so he grabbed his phone
and he filmed himself saying they just
told me to leave they're firing me
because I wear black lives matter Taco
Bell panicked apologized and reinstated
him dude was willing to lose everything
for a mask with a logo on it meanwhile
there's a lot of people who are like
well you know I could but my worst case
scenario is I get yelled at by my boss
or my worst case scenario is I could
lose my job and I have a family to feed
and I'm like I hear you man no I do I do
respect it I'm not I don't want people
to put their families at risk I get it
but I just hope you guys realize the
left is willing to literally burn down
buildings in Georgia leftists torched
two houses flipped the truck over and
set it on fire stolen from a guy they
had gasoline and explosives that's the
length length that they're willing to go
and many people here are like yeah but I
could lose my job it's like those dudes
could blow up right like there there's
videos of edible being set on fire they
keep doing it they're throwing
explosives they're being charged with
Terror and it's not going to stop them
there is a clear you know distinction
between the willingness to engage in
conflict between the two factions
there's the pro-america side that says
we must we must just calm down we must
just mind our own business keep our
heads down and let it all blow over and
there are a lot of people I'd say half
or more that are like no no I'm going to
speak up I'm going to stand up I will
never back down I can respect that but I
I look at it like
when we had Rick Santorum on and he said
we can't impeach Joe Biden no no we
can't do that we've got to play by the
rules we gotta and I'm like impeaching
Joe Biden doesn't accomplish anything
but a symbolic victory in the first
place if you're unwilling to just even
wave a sign saying we mad because it's
so it's decorum well then you're gonna
lose yeah yeah the the right has still
not learned the lesson that you have to
fight fire with fire and it like they're
so concerned about being uh moral right
but we're the moral ones right I think
you can fight fire with fire with a
controlled burn they'll like burn a
stretch that the fire stops but I'm just
asking people on the right to Fight Fire
with water right we don't want a
destructive force right we just need
there to be some of it yeah and so
what's happening is if a bunch of people
are like look man I can't bail water
with you because I'll get too close to
the flames and you know I don't want to
risk hurting my hands I got kids to feed
it's like well there are people out here
who are currently being singed and
burned for you
and and many of them are respecting your
decision not to be involved and well but
and not just for you but for your
children that's what that's what that's
where and I again I understand and I try
to be empathetic to that view but I'm
like I have the children too and I'm out
there doing the hard work you know why
because I want my children to have a
better place for them when they grow up
why else do it right I mean if if it's
just for us well I mean by the time it
gets that bad maybe we'll you know help
see I think there's a whole wave of
people who are like watching you fight
the fire and they're over here being
like the fire is getting closer do a
better job I don't understand like right
I I think that there is such a sense
that it is not your responsibility and
that's where I come back to like if you
don't live by the values that you expect
everyone else to promote then like what
are you doing you're not helping at all
let me pull up this story here for you
guys from timcast.com Disney Affiliated
drag queen welcomes children to show
featuring simulated sex and nudity it's
not just simulated sex it is simulated
sodomy where two men go up on stage in
front of children and simulate sodomy
and um I'm surprised to see this a
little bit because here we go Katie
Porter Democrat from California said
that groomer and pedophile are just
identities and that you know people are
attacking them for their identities as
if they've committed a criminal act and
it's like well grooming is in my opinion
and you want to make an argument about
someone just being a pedophile they
haven't done anything fine but that's an
insane thing for a Democrat to say but
it's because they're moving the Overton
window first they said drag shows are
just fashion it's dancing and then once
all the left got on board and said we
that they defend these things and the
right's crazy they've now graduated to
drag shows where I can't show you the
image not on YouTube it is exposed
breasts like simulated breasts that but
like not a bra not a not a fake bust
quite literally nipples and everything
on this person's chest called tits in a
box and then there's actually a dude
wearing a thong and it and he turns
around and Giggles tihi with his ass to
the kids and then it shows like the
spiral level his ass around him and then
you actually have two guys doing it on
stage simulating doing it on stage okay
so when here here's what I see happening
the people on the right who have
families have everything to lose and so
they don't want to take the risk the
people on the left have literally
nothing to lose so they'll risk anything
and everything that's asymmetrical
conflict and it ends with a very obvious
outcome so if you are in a short-term
perspective such as I can't lose my job
I have kids I have to feed them I
totally get it far be it for me to tell
you what to do just as long as you know
this is the world you are leaving for
your children if you're okay with that
then by all means do nothing if this is
terrifying you and and and and and
making you concerned maybe you should
consider what standing down means for
your children when they get older but
maybe you want your kids to be on stage
with these guys I don't know these kids
are watching it all happen they're
they're being groomed by overt
sexualization in these shows it is
escalating they are incrementalizing
more and more and more and this ends
with them actually abusing the kid kids
in these events it started with a drag
show where our drag queen dances the
next thing we saw was it's not going to
lick itself then we saw children taking
their clothes off on stage for fermented
a gay bar now you have them simulating
sodomy in front of children and they
were what do you think happens next I
hope you're happy about what the world
will be if you don't want to be involved
okay I'm not telling you what to do
because I get it risk is scary and I
mean that seriously but just as long as
you understand this is what awaits your
children
yeah this one was um the worst we so
defend our kids Texas my organization
sent Taylor Hansen out to this
particular drag show to get the footage
um I re I did the research on this it's
a drag queen Christmas tour they've got
like I think 38 different stops across
the country that they're going to
um way more than I'm comfortable with in
Texas I think that was four or five just
in Texas and um the thing about this one
is that
on the ticketing website it did say all
age is welcome it did in most cases it
did give some sort of a very very soft
warning like this is adult so just be
careful but all age is welcome so
typically the the response that I get
from the left is well they did give some
sort of warning okay well why then in
this particular show did they constantly
Target the children because we have
video after video after video of all of
these performers speaking to the
children in the crowd calling them up to
the stage interviewing them putting them
on the mic all while they're also
explaining there was one part where one
of the the performers talked about a
sexual act that they had with their
father's boss and detailed it right and
then went around the audience and had
the audience share their favorite sex
stories no wings with children with
children knowing that there were
children in the audience they knew this
because they were conversing with them
on the microphone so for everyone who
wants to say well it's not the drag
queen's fault they didn't add their just
saying all ages welcome just because
they want to be welcoming and they want
to be inclusive they could very very
easily make this 18 and up 21 and up if
they wanted to there's a reason why they
called out to those children they called
them up to the stage they received tips
from them there is a reason why they are
doing that yeah in this particular video
too that you mentioned specifically I
think it's that person with the the
bazunkas out that clearly was
interviewing yes a small child and what
the bazangas with I I don't think I
don't know I I I don't remember but I
remember seeing this clip going uh you
know around on Twitter specifically
asking a child who was barely able to
speak what's your favorite part of the
show child's like nothing yeah I feel
sorry for these kids
parents thinking bringing them out to
this and then and again the police have
no upside to do anything about it but
this over the sexualization what does it
do to children it ruins their
possibilities of having cohesive
relationships ruins their possibility of
having family members gets them hooked
onto adult contents Rob their innocence
gets rid of their ability to have a
childhood so that there's so many layers
to this that essentially for me at the
end of the day boiled down to a
depopulation agenda some people might
say it's a degeneracy agenda whatever it
is this is this is sick this is not good
and this is not something children
should be around it can be both right
like it can be a depopulation agenda at
the top and just a degeneracy problem at
you know with at the bottom yeah I think
that that's because a lot of people keep
asking why do children need to be there
but why do guys have to dress in front
of children to be the bigger question
why do you as an adult male have to do
this in front of children and if you
didn't like it you wouldn't Target the
children in the show it's a simple
question
what would happen if the bazunga's
dancer went to a grade school playground
and just walked around
at this point it'd probably be tolerated
no no it would think so a father would
get up or if there was a father a lot of
families are fatherless when like we
can't show the images of what they did
on YouTube because YouTube will say this
is not Advertiser friendly but for some
but the issue is police even though it
is already illegal won't do anything
about it so when I say something like
this I am outright abolish the police
100 this is already child sexual
exploitation and the cops aren't doing
anything about it so why have cops if
they won't even stop that in Texas yeah
Instagram took it down Instagram took
videos and photos of this down but but
but but it's okay and they also took
down like didn't Taylor put up like they
removed my post and it's like a smaller
version and they took that one down too
like it doesn't make any sense I think
what's strange to me is Most states have
laws against like you can't show
children pornography right you're not
allowed to show them simulated sexual
acts so when cops say well there's
nothing we can do about it like that
can't possibly be true because this is
within at least in Most states the
definition of something that is not
allowed they are choosing not to pursue
it and whether that's because you know
there's no criminal complaint by the
parents who bought tickets and brought
their children or you know what is the
company going to do be like oh I think
we made a mistake please prosecute us
like you need you need someone to be
complaining theoretically although the
cops do have the right you know law
enforcement could theoretically
press charges they're just opting not to
Texas yeah I know I know and that is
what is so infuriating to me as well I'm
like if this is if and this is what I
think part of their plan is in pushing
this in Texas because some of the most
egregious ones that we've done the one
at ebb and flow that you guys probably
saw with the guy that was uh dancing to
the sexually explicit p word song with a
young girl that was right there
um I I took that video and I kept
telling myself how in the world is this
happening in Texas and you know you got
to believe that they are so arrogant
that they think if we can get this done
in Texas where can we not get this done
right because Florida
that's the only place right that's the
only place but I think it's like if you
are a liberal in Texas you see yourself
as like someone in occupied territory
yeah you're being so Progressive by
taking your child to this and how dare
these backwards conservative people
wrong this thing that should be I don't
know what fun I'm not sure what the
adjective is for them but like I think
it's to connect with these people who
are so kind of moving down a radical
path especially in their parenting that
they feel as though they are morally
correct and when there is Backlash they
double down on what they do someone
should interview these parents and just
be like after the show why are you
bringing your child here why do you
think this is okay I I would I I'm
curious because they're either brain
dead they're they're you know they're
they're either you know fluoride brained
out or or just totally out of it or just
really bad people well they will be in
Dallas tomorrow night and maybe I just
might happen to be there asking them
those questions yeah where where are the
police
uh oftentimes they are called so they
show up but usually they get stuck
trying to maintain peace between antifa
who always shows up and the protesters
who always show up and they uh they say
there's no violation they say there's no
violence we can't do well right but uh I
think the cops are are probably in on it
I completely agree with you and so for
us the the most reasonable solution for
us is to go to the legislators and say
you need to strengthen the language and
make sure that it is clear that this is
child abuse make sure that it is
prohibited what else do you do in this
moment to protect kids so well I'll
start with this
we often talk about how uh the law is is
less relevant than culture there are
laws on the books in I can't remember
what city it was I was reading a book
and it was like putting a pie in your
windowsill is illegal unless it's like
Tuesday or something and it was a law
that used to be there because of wild
animals being attracted to the small
town but now that it's a big city it
makes no sense why you can't be on the
you know top of your building you know
put a pie out the window so no cop will
enforce that law we are at the point
where police are completely okay with
this there in New York there's an
interesting cultural thing where women
are allowed to walk around topless
but a lot of these cops are more
conservative so there's one particular
woman who's morbidly obese and she walks
around with her massive bazangas
flopping around and she gets arrested
all the time and then immediately files
a lawsuit and wins instantly and gets
several thousand dollars because the
cops see her and say ma'am you can't do
that and she goes yes I can they say
you're under arrest then the cops find
out it's actually allowed
see culturally among those cops in New
York they see it and say I have to stop
it there's no law they know of right
it's just wrong to them right the cops
here was a San Antonio uh Austin Austin
this one was Austin to the cops in
Austin this is perfectly fine just like
the parents think so no no law that
could be written is going to make the
cops enforce this but if you you need
Abbott to send in state troopers yeah
yeah well I mean you're not wrong I have
been to some where the cops do see I can
see it on their face it does seem like
they want to do something but they feel
like their hands are tied because of
their superiors I'm not I'm not covering
for them
for them that's an excuse right well
right like I've seen I've seen cops
arrest people for nothing I watched a
video out of Florida where a guy got
arrested because he was a blind guy with
a walking cane and they're watching two
dudes simulate sodomy in front of
children like well you know this one's
too ambiguous for us yeah you kidding me
well there's people who pee outside they
get charged with indecent exposure right
yeah that happens routinely all the time
perhaps in in Texas want this that's the
only explanation well more importantly
with all the the events that I've
attended it's you know as you would
expect it's almost exclusively what
appears to be single mothers uh taking
their young children no fathers usually
right no fathers and and what is so
fascinating to me is I'm like
where the hell are the dads in the
community why are they not coming here
they are all walking in they're not
screaming it down they're not doing all
of the things that I would want and
expect you know my husband to do if this
came to my community and you know my
child or other my friend's children were
participating in it or whatever uh where
is that urgency of the men in these
communities to say we're not letting you
do this in our town it's it's really
frightening to me but men who do that
are you know toxically masculine and
they're not who cares I don't care I
think it'd be a good thing but I'm just
saying that like the same way that cops
who might in their gut be like this is
wrong I can see this is wrong but I
don't know how to move forward because I
don't think I have any law to arrest
them I don't know who I address whatever
I think men who are in these communities
like are you gonna tell if you're if you
have a sister who has a young child
you're a man who's going to take your
niece or nephew to one of these shows
like do you say like no you can't take
them and start some family riff like I
think people are afraid to speak up I
agree with you but I think that there is
so much I have seen cops arrest people
by going uh you can't go there it's a
frozen Zone and the person says what's
Frozen zone mean it means you can't go
there and then the person goes okay so
it's walking you're under arrest I've
seen people get arrested for resisting
arrest meaning they weren't actually
being arrested there was nothing to
resist and they're being arrested for
the act of resisting arrest that wasn't
happening and these cops are like well
you know they are shaking big fake tits
in front of children and simulating sex
acts which is child exploitation but uh
far be it for me to know the law I was
arrested seven times seven times I had
to go to jail why routinely asking
questions right so so to see this level
this is why I have a lot of my points
and viewpoints because seeing the
absurdity in our society where you get
in trouble for asking a politician a
question but you show you're junk to
small kids that somehow is okay it's not
I mean what are the laws that prevent
children from entering strip clubs right
like why is this any different right
right well it's not I mean the LGBT
community is now I think exempt from
laws regarding child exploitation and
child sexual abuse I mean that that's
the only conclusion that I can come to
and if people are not willing to stand
up and do what's right when it comes to
sexual abuse of children like what what
are they willing to stand up for imagine
being a cop
but also being like you know willfully
and knowingly only enforcing you know
like Revenue generation through tickets
and arresting you know legitimate
protesters while ignoring antifa and
this yeah like I can only assume the
good cops retired defund the police
worked and the cops that are left are
totally on board with it that's what
they wanted they wanted a police force
that would be subservient we saw this in
Seattle when a bunch of antifa people
were like approaching it out with
weapons and he was backing up and a cop
vehicle pulls up gets out grabs the
victim and arrests him and then
apologizes to antiva that's where we're
at we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com to support our work directly
uh we got a bunch of really awesome
stuff at the website but we got a bunch
of cool stuff uh happening on the ground
we have secured a building we're gonna
be setting up a physical hangout Cafe
the first floor is gonna be a cafe
second floor is going to be like a skate
shop and a gaming shop third floor is
going to be podcasts and stuff so we
might do special Friday night events
there and uh the goal ultimately is by
the by this time next year to have a
bunch of these locations so I think we
can pull it off thanks to your support
and then what happens when we have a
bunch of physical locations people can
actually meet up in have Saturday
Saturday morning events with their
families this is the kind of thing I
think we need to do to shift the culture
it's one thing I can do it's a small
grain of sand in a much bigger heat but
it's something we're working on thanks
to your support let's read
all right Carolyn Clark says Sarah I
live in downtown Roanoke Texas a few
blocks from that place thank you for
what you're doing to protect children
love you thank you I appreciate that
absolutely Adam Noel says graphene and
Fusion Energy the future looks bright
have you all discussed the Fusion Energy
breakthrough yet we did we did uh Ian
transitioned today though so uh you know
Ian is is now Hannah Claire Hannah
uh yeah no Ian is sick and so he's
definitely coming back no I'm just
getting Ian really is sick and I'm here
filling in for him
did you Lysol that no for you Kellen
what did you Lysol this did you
absolutely my soul
I think he had to get up super early to
do a cast Castle episode today yeah
that's not normal it was like 10 a.m and
that's if like the people watching Ian's
nocturnal he does not ever see wow
he's like a vampire what's what's what's
the word for like a cat that sleeps all
day you know Garfield crepuscular
or muscular they're they're awake during
Dawn and dusk that's it yeah Ian's awake
right before the sun sets to come on the
show and he goes to bed then you know
well he actually doesn't wake up at dawn
so it's literally just sundown
whatever he's the best also stay away
from Lysol yeah yeah I know I said Lysol
I'm like I don't even own Lysol whatever
that came to mind essential oil like I
use thieves Darko says I can't tell if
Luke and Hannah actually don't like each
other or if they're just messing around
and you'll never know we hate each other
we can't stand each other it did feel my
first time on the program it felt a
little tense
yeah we grew up together in Poland
um
okay what do we got
Jason sierkio says I found out another
one of my friends passed away from
overdose today can we please get a
prayer for the still sick and suffering
addict sorry to hear it man my thoughts
go out and if everybody wants to say a
prayer for for you know these people who
are sick and suffering addiction then it
would be greatly appreciated
Guardsman norheim says the world is
falling apart the future is getting very
Grim dark and Henry Cavill is now
spearheading a Warhammer 40K TV series
with Amazon is that is that bad news or
is that good news I heard people were
really excited about it I don't know
I think they did Henry Cavill dirty he
was The Witcher he quits The Witcher to
be Superman and then they can him from
from Superman for what to do a young
Superman ah they have no idea they
ruined DC I mean Marvel has started
going down as well but uh DC is just a
mess Brad dasovich is outside the studio
door pounding his fists with something
to say I can just feel it pop culture
Christ everybody make sure you follow
pop culture crashes on YouTube for our
pop culture content
Let's see we got Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim the time uh the time is now the
time is now was years ago oof we're in a
war for the mines War of the minds for
the minds of children too many own the
libs grifters out here what yes think
about a digital Army fire with fire to
keep it peaceful
I think the issue is just um if
everybody just spoke up there would be
no conflict it would be over but what's
happening is these Democrats like Katie
Porter
she knows that if she comes out against
grooming she will lose votes she knows
that conservatives won't vote for her
anyway and she knows Democrats either
support it or too stupid to think
otherwise so she will support it
if every single person told their
neighbor that's nasty then people like
Katie Porter would stop because they're
like oh too many people are telling me
no
that's the simplest uh the simplest way
to go go about it I suppose but ballot
harvesting you know I do think
legislation matters culture shifting
matters we'll see how it goes I don't
think we're losing though Elon Musk is
definitely a major win with the purchase
of Twitter and the the revelations
that's going on it's it's probably one
of the most powerful moves upward that
we've seen in a long time
red muskrat says Sarah has more balls
than most men today
yes I wish that weren't true
yep there yep well maybe it's the soy I
think it is
I like how people say that's that that
conspiracy pyramid said soy boys is a
conspiracy theory like what men are
losing testosterone the Y chromosome
shrinking all that stuff I'm getting man
bazunkas man bazunkas it's because
they're eating all that gluten the Bill
Gates
seed oils right no damn right
glycopy high fructose corn syrup all
that
Omega rasetsu says Luke is wrong
capitalism is exactly what leftists say
it is capitalism was coined by Louis
Blanc as a straw man against free market
economics meaning head of cattle whose
goal is oligarchy yeah when the
government prints money out of thin air
and then gives it to all their friends
that's not really capitalistic Behavior
it's socialism for the super rich let's
call it what it is and if we had a free
market capitalistic country we wouldn't
have all these monopolies and all these
bigger problems like we do right now so
that's my two cents
all right
Josh Johnson says question for Sarah end
world hunger or send all Creeper
Predators via musk rocket on a one-way
trip let's just call it outer space
I'm going with the I'm going with the
musk rocket musk rocket maybe we can
have all of the really awful people
because we don't want violence to befall
people so I put them in a rocket and we
have them colonize Mars then it'll be
like Australia though like isn't that
what happened with Australia I mean
Australia's Got Its problems they turned
out bad yeah it's gotten pretty bad in
Australia and how funny like how weird
would it be if we put all of like all
criminal predators and everything is
like their sentence was to be loaded up
in a rocket and sent like Alpha Centauri
and then it's just like Earth a thousand
years later and everything's like really
nice and peaceful and there's no crime
and then all of a sudden a gigantic
dick-shaped ship starts arriving all the
Predators are coming back the
family-friendly show
okay
and what do we have becoming
ungovernable says well give your ID card
to the Border guard yeah your Alias says
your captain Jean-Luc Picard of the
United Federation of planets because he
won't speak English anyway music notes
music notes I have no idea
leprechaun says Jon Stewart did nothing
shocking stop pretending they made up
thoughts that divulge from the norm he
was simple no hate in the statement dude
gets too much credit for talking also my
birthday is 17th lol love y'all happy
birthday appreciate it Happy Birthday
soulless Ginger says Luke's law of names
if a woman's name has three or more
syllables it will be truncated to suit
Luke's preference thank you I think
someone understands me sorry my name is
too complicated for you I guess I didn't
think it was that bad but it's a lot
it's okay Leonard it's okay it's a
mouthful Leroy it was Leroy please call
me by my respected uh Leroy
personofco.com Leroy Logan Culver says
Michael malice's new book the white pill
is now available on Amazon let's get him
to number one ladies and gentlemen you
really should check out Michael malice's
new book on Amazon the white pill it's
uh it's it's a white pill story but it
talks about dictators I don't I don't
want to just check it out take a look uh
I I talked to Michael a little bit a
little bit about it and we really are
hoping that a book about that grants
some kind of optimism at the very least
will uh reach number one and as we're
talking about all these really really
dark things give it a read and support
support the people who are are fighting
the good fight calling out the machine
in the cathedral and that's Michael
Mouse we're big fans shout out Michael
um look forward to having you on next
time and hopefully we your book hits
number one so we'll give you more shouts
shout outs when we can
let's grab some more Super chats
crypto Pepe says Tim bought 45 Trump
nfts yesterday for 4 455 doubled my
money overnight we'll meet with Trump
for dinner I'll tell him to stop
dwelling on 2020 and ballot Harvest for
20 to 24 if I can cheaper than Times
Square ad Fair Point you actually made
it over there the 45 uh you bought 45
out of 45 000 you actually won the trump
dinner I mean that's amazing I wonder
how Trump dinners were in there that's
that's like I mean the odds aren't that
bad to be completely honest yeah you
know spend five grand get dinner with
Trump I actually thought the cocktail
party at Mar-A-Lago was the better prize
because like you know hanging out with
Trump's cool but that's your whole thing
yeah whereas like the Marla cocktail
party is like you're hanging out you're
having drinks your schmooz and you're
walking around you bring your friends
it's like a lot of different people how
much did you have to buy for that do you
know you could buy one it was like yeah
okay yeah
and uh I mean it's really interesting
that the Trump nfts doubled in value
instantly super cool congratulations the
I have no issue with the Trump cards
themselves I have no issue with the
infomercial I thought it was actually
funny the issue was the timing of it he
said there's gonna be a major
announcement and then it's he's selling
nfts
he sold them all in a couple hours I
mean the dude made money legit and it
was a funny commercial he you know when
he said he was better than Lincoln and
Washington but winning dinner with him
he's not sure if it was a great prize I
I love how he does that because most
people doing sales are going to be like
it's the best prize ever he's like I
don't know if it's actually that good
you know if you like me I guess but he
is the best president ever I know right
I just felt like it was like if you
haven't thought of what to get a boomer
in your life please get them this nft
Boomers don't understand nfts though
yeah but it's the thought that counts
you know people still do it for Trump
yeah people bought him man you tell them
it's an ft they're like is that what the
kids are into cool
does it help Trump I'm in yeah that's
what they said setham says can Raymond g
Stanley Jr get a t-shirt or a plaque on
the wall he's earned it that's true he
has I don't know we can do something
which wall
yeah well we're building the new studio
right now it's coming along really
really awesomely and so I'm really
excited for that to be done but who
knows because things have been taking
forever but uh the new space is going to
be so amazing
the studio is slightly bigger and
there's a green room attached to it with
a window and then it's overlooking this
massive building it's a 40 foot tall
building so there's going to be just all
sorts of really awesome stuff that we're
gonna have there it's gonna be really
great awesome skating music uh we're
gonna have like a fake little table game
thing for people to play either board
games or you know fake casino games
super excited for that
yep
what do we got where are we at
well what is this Quantum strange Quark
says Elon should release them now if
they pin an apology for seven days
otherwise they get a 14-day suspension
love me love me some Sarah Gonzalez oh
thank you
my proposal was Elon
let all of the journalists come back
but
in order to come back they agree to
allow us to produce a real-time tracker
of their locations that will be pinned
to their profile
hey they got no problem with it they
it's just reporting public information
right so uh uh I think it's a fair
compromise yeah yeah I love their home
address in their bio yeah they can come
back well real-time tracking locations
right I agree you think I'm joking Elon
send them a message right now send
Danielle Sullivan a message say Donnie I
understand you were just reporting so
here's the compromise I will reinstate
your account so long as we can attach a
link to a real-time tracker review
you know what they're going to say
they're going to say no and then Elon
can come out and said look they said it
was fine to report on someone's
real-time location and so when I said
okay you're right I'll let you back on
the platform if we could do the same to
you they refused no why would they do
that
I think it's wild like they work at
these places that were like yes yes
totally fine share their you know doxed
information like I I we wouldn't do that
like I don't understand how you as a
journalist like yes I guess it's been
made public but like it is still wrong
to report it so you're just recycling
the crime like I don't really get it I
mean from the same brand of journalists
who reported that Trump peed on a bunch
of people with no verification or
anything like that and everyone else ran
with that as well the elevator story you
saw that one no The Huffington Post
random story saying somewhere
some at some point a video was made
about Donald Trump doing something in an
elevator what he was doing we don't know
where was it we're not sure the elusive
white whale and it's like what
that's a real story no yeah yeah yeah I
remember yeah you want to try and Google
it or something you can pull up the
exact headline oh man it's like nothing
happened but we think maybe something
happened somewhere when they wrote a
story about it well they like proved
that it didn't
prove that it didn't happen that's
that's the new state of Journalism just
prove that it didn't happen OMG puppy
says olberman Taylor Lorenz Etc I wonder
how much cluster B personality disorder
is there histrionic personality disorder
narcissistic personality disorder Etc oh
yeah it's all there I mean these people
are nuts
they are just crazy people
Taylor runs is like I didn't go to
private school and then someone like
pulls out the Tweet where she's like I
did go to private school like I just
don't follow it she is the worst
where are we at
Emissary of dickishness says yo the
Trump meme nfts sold out within 24 hours
haha I think it was like a couple hours
I think it was way less than 24. you
know I think it was very quickly Robert
Owen says memorialize bocus by making a
plushy line with the funds going towards
Animal Care kind of like a pet HSA
that's a really good idea I will uh I
will I will write that down and I will
look into that bocus uh bocus is spelled
b-u-b-o-k-u-s plushies is it uh-huh why
how did you spell bogus I don't know I
feel like every time I the first like
couple months that I worked here every
time I met him someone pronounced his
name slightly differently that's exactly
right yeah his name's actually bucko
yeah that's what I thought but you've
never called him back yeah I did in the
early days so uh an update on Mr bocus
his uh red blood cell count has improved
after the blood transfusions the IV
fluids have dramatically improved his
um demeanor
unfortunately however we got news today
that he has entered stage four kidney
failure
the doctors don't know how long he'll
last stage four is very serious it's
like the end his kidneys have basically
failed but with the treatment and
medication we're giving him they say it
could be six months it could be a lot
less so depend based on what I've heard
from people it could be several months
and the way he's been acting he's very
thirsty because his kidneys have failed
but he's actually acting rather normally
now since we got him medicine and IV
fluid treatment so it's really crazy you
you you pinch the skin and because their
skin is so loose and then you just Jam
the needle in and they don't even Flinch
wow like yeah it just goes in and they
just look at you like did you do
something and then the fluid goes under
their skin and then it's like a bubble
and then it goes down and then all of a
sudden he's jumping around all excited
like I don't want to say jumping around
but he like he got up he's walking
around he's yelling he's acting more
normal and it's like okay that's good
the sad news is he's only four
but he's got a genetic problem genetic
heart problem and a genetic genetic
kidney problems the good news I suppose
is if if the doctors are saying we don't
know how long he can last because of
this but it could be maybe even six
months that gives Ian enough time to
contact these stem cell doctors who he's
been trying to reach out to and maybe
get some stem cell treatments for him or
something I just think the issue is stem
cells seem like they could probably cure
someone who's got deteriorating organs
not not someone who's got defective
organs yeah like he he's got a heart
problem like a genetic heart defect the
stem cells aren't going to correct that
you know they're going to just attach to
what's already there
and with with the kidneys being totally
failed I don't know if anything's gonna
work but uh I appreciate all of the well
wishes
we'll grab some more Super chats
where are we at
Satan the sir says did you all see the
net job growth estimation for Quarter
Two was actually closer to ten thousand
five hundred than the 1.1 million
initially reported no there is no typo
there oh gosh
wow
John Paul says Tim please shut up my
girlfriend Tina it's her birthday and
she's a huge fan Tina happy birthday
awesome thanks for being a fan we really
do appreciate it
I hope they're watching the show for her
birthday that'd be cool yeah I'd love it
Joseph Murphy says my brother gave me a
PS2 DBZ budakai 2 Thug two oh wow Tony
Hawk's Underground and others for my
30th birthday present 12 22. so I'm
having a great night listening while I
play as Goku that sounds pretty awesome
yeah I bought uh an N64 a Super Nintendo
on a PlayStation recently and then I
play I was playing Breath of Fire I
played Chrono Trigger for a little bit
and then I played Breath of Fire for a
little bit
uh good old days man but it's really
funny being an adult with the current
level of video games and then playing
something like Breath of Fire for those
that are familiar and I'm like wow this
game has nothing in it it's so basic
there's like nothing and it used to be
like the craziest game ever when I was a
little kid
Arthur Des marai says everything is
backwards we should know everything
about the government and they should
know nothing about us the news should
tell us facts and let us make our
opinion now they hide the facts and tell
us their opinion yup chicken Sushi says
wow Ian got hot
I've always thought he had great hair
my hair is anywhere close to Ian's I'm
excited
John H says go with me on this maybe
Trump's big announcement was about
fighting back on the First Amendment but
someone sent out the nft stuff first to
screw him if Milo can mess with Trump
why not someone else
you know it does seem Trump to do the
nft thing as his major announcement and
his post was this is the major
announcement uh you're right it could be
a staffer but I think the simple answer
is whoever advised Trump to do this
gave him bad advice so I would say
technically you're correct I don't know
if it's to screw him it was just a bad
idea
but I the only bad idea was the timing
if you put up the free speech thing
first it would have hit like a hammer
then he could have done the nft things
as uh wink wink we got one more for you
and it would have been funny
the the order they put it in um came out
bad came out bad but it's cool the nfts
made him a ton of money so you know who
who really wins in the end the guy
walking away with about five million
bucks
or the people complaining about you know
he definitely doesn't have enough of
money
he doesn't have well is there enough
money
yeah for Trump who knows
drad Mack says hey Luke I just checked
elon's follows and I didn't see you but
I saw Tim
just wanted to see you squirm
I'm checking right now
no no that didn't happen sorry oh no
wait he's right I got a DM
live hold on I have a text what is this
I've already been through this joke
before Tim all right no no I do I'm
gonna hear it again come on he says uh
oh it's Elon uh-huh yeah hey hey Tim I
accidentally followed Luke the other day
but I meant to follow you just wanted to
let you know Luke is totally dumb oh man
well that was that was hurtful you know
I can't for the sake of Poe's law I
would Elon did not DM me because there's
going to be someone out there who's
going to be like Tim's claiming Elon
Musk The Daily Beast I'm gonna message
him about you all right they're gonna
stop him right now I will tell you on
says Luke I'll tell on Elon
you'll tell on Elon yeah Elon comes on
this show just to moderate fights
between you guys he's like I have a
million Sons I've been through this
before
fat Sean says the correct name for the
crime of grooming is enticement of a
minor well there you go hmm that's right
well also well I don't know if we're
gonna talk about how much we can talk
about grooming but grooming talks to
like
systematic exposure to get people to
normalize let me let me let me give you
guys for those that listen to My Morning
Show the Temple Daily Show
um check out the Temple Daily Show on
iTunes Spotify or on youtube.com timcast
if you guys haven't but um the simplest
way to explain grooming
a young woman is approached by a guy
like the mall and he was like Hey do you
do you do modeling and she's like no and
he goes here's my card give me a call
you know and she's like 16 or whatever
and he's like we we're a modeling agency
so we do a bunch of photos I think you
can make a ton of money doing this
you're gonna be great and then he talks
she talks to her parents and her parents
like yeah online modeling agency this is
this is really good stuff okay cool
let's go
16 year old girl meets the guy
everything's above board he says we're
going to do a raincoat with an umbrella
picture picture picture wonderful here's
300 you guys were awesome we'll call you
again
totally normal right the next time she
comes in he's like we're gonna do
sportswear so you're gonna be wearing
yoga pants and it's totally normal stuff
you normally wear photo photo photo
photo they do that a couple times
eventually the the girl is going in by
herself mom's totally cool with her kids
new job and then he says we're gonna do
swimwear
beanies and stuff yeah you go to the
beachy do bikinis it's all the same
they do this until eventually it's like
okay now I want you to drop your
shoulder strap okay now we're gonna do
some nightlife stuff now we've got an
artistic shoot for an art magazine it's
going to be topless but you've already
done the bikini stuff so this is totally
the same they do that until the woman is
then sold off and trafficked into a
foreign country or something like that
and then she's a young you know traffic
human that's like generic grooming as
most people have probably heard about it
the fake modeling gig or the you know
come come to Hollywood and I'll give you
a gig and before they know what they're
doing porn or it's like teachers like
saying to their kids like oh so you have
a boyfriend right oh I talk to my
teacher all the time right oh man your
boyfriend's so lucky like and it keeps
going and getting more and more perverse
until there's another relationship it
was the first drag shows for families it
was drag queen Story Hour they're just
reading books oh calm down then it was a
drag show for kids they're just dancing
now it's simulated sodomy on stage that
is grooming I called it you called it I
was saying like they're going to
increment this this is what grooming is
and then all the Media Matters there
were like two pools are bigger yeah so
wouldn't you argue that the parents are
being groomed though because they're
they're the ones taking their kids to
these shows the kids aren't voluntarily
going and buying these tickets it's the
parents I I that's a good point I'd say
to a degree you can say the parents are
being
um psychologically groomed to to
allowing their kids to be trafficked but
that that happens too there will be a
woman who has who has like a single
mother with a kid and an abusive
boyfriend comes in and they starts
gaslighting her withholding money or
pressuring her and then eventually
trafficking the kid yeah you hear a lot
of those stories happen they're scary
man
all right gpt3bot says I refuse to take
my company's Dei courses so I'm writing
a bot to take them for me I'm going to
send my GitHub link to HR troll them
with code nice
I think it's all of your uh co-workers I
mean what happens if you fail the Dei
course
yeah actually here's my advice to you
take the course but film
set up a camera could you get get one of
those uh phone tripods and point at the
computer screen
and then start taking the course and the
moment they disparage in any way any
race or identity because they will white
people this then you have a grievance
against them for racial discrimination
the question I suppose is Will the
government do anything about it well I
don't know but you can probably still
find a lawyer who will you know put him
to the coals and then they might be like
uh we're getting sued over this these
Dei courses often disparage white people
which is illegal so see what you can do
all right tough news for you guys
tough news what do you mean what he's a
person he's not white oh I see I see
well it's been a rough time for us white
people what can I say yeah Kellen Kellen
are you white uh well I'm a quarter
polish so you tell me okay
in your quest for power you need to make
anyone agree with you so a single
percentage is a weapon for you no I
don't need an ally
I want to be the only special one here
okay you got to be like hey you know now
there's two of us and we can vote
against you yeah but then I I don't have
any respectful privileges I just want
all the Privileges I think I got Santa
Clara's the only white person here I am
the token white person are you polish no
I'm not uh I also think I don't want to
assume Ian's race here but I also think
he's a token white person so yeah but
he's not here right now uh are you are
you a white person Sarah you no yeah
yeah I didn't think so and of course I'm
I'm Asian so we've got two you're like a
quarter Asian okay
doesn't count it I'm outnumbered you
should hate me hold on was Obama the
first black president
was he the first Asian President
25
percent of Obama to be the first black
president therefore he was like half
white half yeah yeah I know but everyone
said he was the first black guy half
could be the cutoff point I'm sending it
officially as the officials
as the only person of color here I'm I'm
laying down the law right now 50 that's
it you can't claim it unless you're 15.
hold on hold on oh man you don't have
enough votes I don't care yeah I got
special privileges but I'm more special
you threw you threw out your your extra
I don't need it Kellen want to join my
alliance
in prison uh it's just my voting block
please don't make this and do a bigger
deal than it is
no I don't know I think it was part
Indonesian no uh here's what I know if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com to support our
work directly I am really excited about
the the cafe physical locations and I
think it would be really cool to like
have one in Austin have one in a like
I'd probably want to set up three in
Florida as fast as possible that'd be
super cool so imagine you're just like
you're going out I'm gonna get coffee
and then you're like oh what's this
there's like a new Coffee Spot and you
go in and you're what's on the TV screen
it's Tim cast it's we are change it's
Viva Frey and so people who are coming
in on busy days to get an ice cream or a
coffee the content that's being played
is the content from us and our friends
that would be epic and so I'm like maybe
one day we'll have a thousand of these
locations and whenever someone comes in
to sit down and drink a coffee they're
watching us it's all about expanding the
culture so with your support it's
another big project we have but I will
stress the building's there we have
begun the the the the build out already
we are doing the design work we have the
building we've gone in it is purchased
this is going to be awesome I'm hoping
within the next month it is up and
running in a very rudimentary way but
within a few weeks we will be directly
selling our coffee brand so I'm super
excited for this so thanks for your
thank you all for your support we're
gonna keep just just expanding and doing
stuff the other thing I want to mention
about these coffee shops is that um in
the in the front windows there's going
to be Flags
and it ain't going to be a rainbow it's
going to be a Gadsden flag it's going to
be a molon labe flag and we are going to
outright say like we stand for these
values it's who we are that's all that's
that's it we're not going to cower we're
not going to put up please don't hurt us
antifa we're going to be like yo we're
right here
and we're gonna and we're gonna stand up
for what we believe in so I'm really
excited for this you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Sarah do you want to shout
anything out
uh yeah but follow me please on social
media Sarah Gonzalez TX and uh my makeup
americanbeauty by sarah.com as well as
the initiative that we are leading in
Texas defend kids tx.com Sarah thank you
so much for coming it was really awesome
thank you for all the work you do if you
want to support a person of color's
business you can by going to Luke
uncensored.com and I just remembered I
actually uh launched this t-shirt a
couple years ago when YouTube fully
demonetized me
um and I also started a members area
Lucan sensor.com is the members area I
do a lot of different content down there
and the latest video I did was uh all
about the Plastics that you find
everywhere including places that you
wouldn't expect to find it Plastics are
really bad for you especially if you're
a male I covered that plus a lot more
Luke uncensored.com see you there uh I'm
Hannah clear brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com thanks for having me on
tonight you can follow me on Instagram
at Hannah claire.beat you can follow me
on Twitter at HC brimlow I think uh you
should definitely follow Tim cast news
on Twitter we're very close to hitting
40 000 subscribers and it's just a great
place to read the best journalism on
Twitter in my opinion where's our gold
check Elon yeah where is our gold check
go Blue I don't understand post
millennial got their gold check oh wow
that's rude yeah so anyways follow Tim
cast news on Twitter and that's all I
have to promote
uh you guys can find me at Kellen PDL it
was a great Friday Night episode to end
the week we got a lot of exciting stuff
happening next week so be sure to tune
in to timcast Monday I think the show's
starting a half an hour early because we
will be on stage at TP USA with the
rotating rotating set of guests I have
no idea how this is going to work it's
gonna be awesome there's gonna be people
screaming stuff so uh thanks for hanging
out everybody and we will see you all
then